people to have more kids in China
today so I recently dug that book out I
thumped through it again and I was
stunned by how wrong its doomsday
projections were uh I I think
brainwashing is probably too strong of a
term uh from Professor Swan who I liked
but I was certainly I think I was
indoctrinated um and despite how wrong
those 70s activists were hysterical
pronouncements continue to this day in
ice a in the 70s was going to be an Ice
Age Ice Age is coming no and then no the
polar ice is melting uh Florida will
soon be underwater I could go on and on
I'm going to uh jump to a few
examples uh both recent and not so
recent on March 20th 2023 a year less
than a year ago the United Nations
warned of Humanity's ticking Time Bomb
quote unquote and they released a report
of reports enumerating multi-trillion
multi-trillion
dollar plan to implement climate
policies across the
globe un Secretary General Antonio
gutterz proclaimed the report quote a
survival guide for Humanity and called
for the phase out of fossil fuels this
is from the UN last year phase out
fossil fuels to save the planet he wrote
dear friends humanity is on thin ice
that is ice that is melting fast some
other quick examples 1982 Mustafa Toba
executive director of the un's this is
years ago the un's environment program
warned of widespread Devastation in less
than 20 years he quoted he said quote an
environmental
catastrophe which will witness that
Devastation as complete as irreversible
as any nuclear Holocaust is upon us this
is
1982 uh back in the 70s uh Harvard
biologist and Nobel Prize winner George
Wald speaking at the University of Rhode
Island said quote Civilization will end
within 15 or 30 years unless immediate
action is taken this isn't the 70s
civilization will end unless immediate
action is
taken uh in the 70s again when I took
this class Greenhouse theorists pushed a
rise in average temperature plenty of
prognosticators predictors said a big
freeze is coming and uh I won't get into
all the stats and projected it's going
to 11° colder by the year 2000 uh ice
age is coming of course that didn't
happen uh so in the 70s Ice Age is
coming but within a couple years
suddenly uh global cooling is not
happening global warming is happening so
the the climate has always changed and I
am not a climate denier so to speak uh
climate has always changed the big issue
is how much is man's activities
impacting climate nobody knows for sure
some say minimally some say a lot we
don't know and some scientists say some
things other scientists say different
things the concern and the reason for
this this uh resolution is
that scientists who don't seem to adhere
to or Gom on to the the most uh extreme
predictions um are being
silenced and that is a concern
uh 2006 former vice president Gore
predicted that unless drastic measures
were implemented the planet would hit
quote an irreversible point of no return
by 2016 well that was eight years ago
and I'm the point of no return was just
not clear as as recently as April of
2008 CNN uh media Mogul Ted Turner Ted
Turner stressed the consequences of
climate action action now he said quote
not doing it will be catastrophic most
of the people will have died and the
rest of us will be cannibals
civilization will have broken down the
droughts will be so bad there'll be no
more corn
growing well the corn is still growing
all these year this is 16 years later uh
just went by Senator Pearl's Farm many a
number of times he's got plenty of corn
growing so Ted Turner was wrong the
cannibalism that he predicted I hope it
doesn't happen I'm not seeing any
imminent
cannibalism uh July uh 2009 a year later
Prince Charles now King Charles Prince
Charles asserted the planet had 96
months to avoid decimation quote
irretrievable climate and ecosystem
collaps and all that goes with it is
imminent uh and one more um January 2019
representative Alexandria acassio Cortez
put her chips on 2031 is the potential
end of days so that hasn't got here yet
it's coming quote Millennials and other
people you know gen Z and all these
folks that will come after us are
looking up and we're like the world is
going to end in 12 years if we don't
address climate and your biggest issue
is how we're going to pay for it and
like this is war this is our World War
II so anyway so there's some examples of
of uh climate activism maybe climate
extremism uh these predictions these
forecasts routinely are
wrong and yet as legislators as
lawmakers we are under incredible
pressures to uh respond to these uh you
know these extremists I think uh calls
for
Action so what prompts this extreme
activism uh media sensationalism is part
of it you know the if if the world is
going to end and that's that's a that's
a story
except that the these these dramatic
warnings of the world then they just
have have don't haven't happened uh
media sensationalism uh green energy
companies of course they do everything
that they can to create uh concerns and
and a demand for green Energy Products
whether it's batteries or solar panels
um or whatever of course they're going
to try to make a case that their
products are needed
um and on and on uh activists activists
need causes they that's that's how they
draw their energy so those of us who
make laws as they just said are
pressured by climate activists to take
action or else we're doomed laws are in
place in some states that eventually ban
not only gas powered vehicles but gas
stoves gas stoves are not here in New
Hampshire yet it's being talked about
here in New Hampshire but there are some
localities and some states that are
phasing out gas stoves they're phasing
out uh gas uh powered
vehicles and is that necessary is it
right uh there are folks here in New
Hampshire that want uh us legislators to
to look at taking similar action uh
people want to mandate electric school
buses is that the best way to go is it
safe is it practical does it work in the
cold um military jets are this's
pressure for them to use organic fuel
regardless of the extra cost uh we've
had bills in this chamber or in this
house to ban wood stoves and that's why
it's relevant to us if we have these
bills whether it's to ban wood stoves or
have buy electric buses or ban gas
stoves like is happening elsewhere is
that good public policy is it based on
good science well we look at scientists
and and the scientists that that said
say wo you know it's not as bad as some
others are saying their voices I we keep
seeing are being stifled farmers and
rancors are now struggling against the
imposition of unreasonable fertilizers
and livestock reduction mandates
So speaking of food it's the activists
who are putting farmers in some cases uh
in bad places because of uh methane we
need fewer cows fewer cows means less
milk means Less meat and so while the
the food problems didn't materialize the
the very folks that worn of them want
policies that are going to create food
short shortages with their Farm policies
fertilizer policies livestock reduction
yes cows create methane how bad is the
methane problem from cows it depends on
who you talk to but the those who who
emphasize the greatest danger in C
methane problems uh are the ones who
seem to drive the
conversation uh so activists often cite
scientific consensus and arguing for
emergency climate action but unlike
political policies we work on consensus
this committee we we try to come to
consensus when we can science is
different science isn't about compromise
it isn't about consensus it isn't about
voting it's about
numbers and facts and
data in scientific is being twisted and
used to promote political agendas
scientists are bullied into signing on
you see all these uh scientists you know
100 scientists signed on for something
some of them later on say I didn't dare
not to sign
on and it's beyond science act I have a
professor background I've been in work
taught at a number of colleges
universities and have done research and
research is being compromised by the
climate activists and extremist Dr
Frederick sites former head of the
United States National Academy of
Sciences wrote in more than 60 years as
a member of the scientific Community I
have never witnessed a more disturbing
Corruption of the peer review process
than the events that now shape climate
change
reports peer review is what happens with
with scholarly papers you your peers
look at them and and give input on them
and
the peer review process has been
corrupted which is a concern to those of
us in
Academia which brings us to the purpose
of this resolution which simply calls
for all the voices to be heard as we
develop climate policies and pass
laws those experts who are being
threatened uh and ignored deserve to be
heard and we need to stop scaring the
heck out of kids the way UNH scared the
heck out of me when I was a freshman
there
most of us agree that measured and
sensible reductions in fossil fuel
emissions are
desirable and we can do that by working
together like we used to the EPA was
established under a Republican
Presidential Administration and together
we've worked and cleaned as I said
earlier we've cleaned our lakes and
rivers we've cleaned our air does
anybody remember how terrible the air
was air pollution in New York City or or
Los Angeles
we've done a great bipartisan job for
decades of working together sensibly to
address pollution and air pollution
water pollution
climate is a little bit different you
know that's where the debate is so
climate to finish up climate extremists
who shut down debate and try to impose
radical measures help create bad
policies and bad laws while silencing
contrary opinions so this resolution
simply calls for us to listen to All
voices just says let's just listen to
everybody and stop shutting out some
voices who don't adhere to the extremist
activist climate agenda as we formulate
policy so if that sounds reasonable then
I hope we can eventually vote Yes to
listen to All voices or if you don't
want to listen to All voices then I
think that would be a concern uh that's
all I have thank you Mr chair take
questions if there are any do we have
any questions yes representative
gagy thank you representative for this
good stuff look I've lived on this
planet for almost 80 years now and I've
heard this from the get-go and you're
talking about comments
here when in the 50s when the mills in
Manchester were running they they were
starting to die but they were still
running you could could go and look at
the marac river and see what kind of
merchandise they were making by the
color of the river red one day green
another day blue another day was just
discharged that's all cleaned up like
you like you said that the uh that has
been cleaned up you can actually swim in
the river now and we're taking uh we're
taking water from the marac river for
our drinking water now also uh I also
remember another uh incident for me back
when I uh started working at the post
office in
1984 and some of my colleagues were
saying what do you want to do that we're
going to be out of business in about two
three years right and although things
might be slowing down and not like they
used to be now the internet still has
not quite taken over and they're still I
still like my letters uh so would you
say that it's a control issue that the
the minority Elite wants to control the
masses by fear I spoke to u a uh some
some time ago
about newspaper uh uh he was tele he's a
television uh uh reporter and he said if
it bleeds it leads so my bottom line
what I got out of that was that keep the
fear before the people so they'll listen
to these controlling Elites would that a
fair assessment thank you for the
comment and the question representative
I totally agree uh you mentioned fear
this is all about fear frankly I think
uh and I many of us are just tired you
know going back uh as you said Decades
of the fear mongering which is going on
uh again I recited when I was a 50 years
ago when I was a freshman at UNH uh they
scared the heck out of me as I've
already as I've already said and you
mentioned the rivers and so it goes back
to working together uh I I one quick
comment on climate uh if you do some
history I in 536 ad during the Dark Ages
there apparently was a huge volcanic
event uh not well recorded it was 536
but if you go back and look at the tree
rings in those days uh apparently the
the the world was dark uh trees didn't
grow in that year the temperatures
plunged now that happened that wasn't
man-made that was due to a volcanic
eruption same thing happened around 1816
I was talking to representative sh
sherff a little bit earlier about 18 New
Hampshire 1816 and froze to death uh
people get the heck out of New Hampshire
why because of volcanic activity Cato
TOA so not that I buy Into Climate
Change man caused but I would say to
some of the activists who are telling us
that we've increased temperature by two
degrees I don't necessarily agree but
let's say that's true if that is true
then the next volcanic eruption where
the the temperatures Dro two degrees
this climate increase might save us
Greenland used to have people living
there 700 years ago anyway I thank you
for your comment and your
question any further
questions go ahead thank you Mr chair
thanks for taking my question would you
believe that uh during lockdowns when
nobody was driving very few people were
driving a lot of the world economy was
kind of shut down people weren't working
uh through that entire year we only uh
reduced carbon emissions by
7%
globally I would believe that coming
from repes repes Manion I'm sure that
that's
accurate any further questions okay I
have a question for the chair do you
feel that this the EV move towards
electric vehicles is sustainable in this
country and what do you feel the outcome
will be if we continue on this path
thank you for the question about EVS
electric vehicles uh I am not a
scientist uh although I I
pay attention to this stuff I'm
concerned in terms of EVS for a lot of
reasons the the batteries is
problematical in terms of some of the
pollution that happens in trying to get
the you know the uh lithium Etc that's
needed for batteries um when it's really
cold these uh the these electric
vehicles have problems that's why the
move for electric buses that we have in
New Hampshire concerns me if if the
buses don't start or if they're not
Dependable or the range decreases in
extreme cold that's a problem I have
with EVS I want to get get smarter about
that uh in the military I I was in a
zoom conference about the military
needing to go green uh I mentioned
earlier about the push for organic jet
fuel it which is much more
expensive um and also using uh where you
can electric vehicles tactically and
there some sense to that they're quieter
but if if you can't depend on them you
can't charge them I mean in the military
you want to accomplish the mission and
uh you know give the commanders what
they need to accomplish the mission so
EVS uh I I think are problematical in
some ways and and I I don't know that
the the the be all and the end
all thank you representative any further
questions have one more representative
gagy thank you you you um just got my
mind going in regards to batteries uh
the was it nickel I forget what what
their name
yeah many people do not realize that in
the
winter it's less effective because the
batteries themselves keep the heat going
to keep their batteries warm so you have
less Road time is that correct Yes again
as I said I'm at a scientist but most of
us understand how cold impacts batteries
and and cold and batteries uh my iPod
which which that didn't work this
morning because it was my car was cold
so cold yes cold is cold and batteries
don't go
together any further questions Carrie do
you think books like the one you read
and Rachel Carson's Silent Spring
actually helped inspired a generation in
the 70s to start cleaning up the dump
they had dumped in the rivers and
landfill and everywhere
else thank you representative I agree
with you uh Silent Spring about the
birds dying from um you
know right uh that profoundly I agree
that profoundly moved people to become
activists uh Mo most of us uh want to
fight pollution you know fighting
pollution and fighting climate change
really are two different things uh but I
I agree that was an important book that
made a difference and they made people
uh aware and and caused people to want
to take action against pollution uh
there's another book called the
population Bomb by Paul Erick in the uh
around 1970 is that was really scary he
said we're really doomed and he was
completely wrong but Rachel Carson
representative I'm all for
her any further questions seeing none
thank you representative Moffett
thank you Mr chair now i' like to call
up
Ma Cal Helen hello
sorry yeah stated I'm bad pronunciation
thank
you there I go great um well thank you
chairman Moffett and members of the
committee
my name is Matthew K elain I'm a
resident of conquer New Hampshire and I
support the bill with a few comments on
how it might be improved um as a brief
background I've worked in public health
issues in New Hampshire for over three
decades focusing on environmental
hazards um measuring Health impacts uh
taking action to reduce risks um from
2013 to 2022 I led a program in DHHS
that specifically focused on weather
climate and uh Health outcomes I
published several peer-reviewed studies
and continue to work on Research with my
partners at Dartmouth and UNH and and
Antioch um I'm an instructor in Antioch
and Environmental Studies department and
currently a private consultant a bit
about my background um the reason I
emphasize weather versus climate because
I think it's misunderstood quite a lot
of the time and that's what I really try
to emphasize my work understanding the
difference in working with it um I
believe the bill does contain some
language that can be improved by
removing references to fraudulent
research and intimidation even if those
do occur in rare cases I believe this
bill asked an important question what is
truth um I would propose to you that
truth is a balanced mixture of two
elements that is accurate information
and a trusted messenger um in this age
of disinformation and and polarization
it's a question we all have to ask
ourselves about the truth over and over
while challenging our own assumptions
and our biases that's what I tried to do
when I was a public servant really
trying to understand what truth was and
then say it in in a trusted way so
people could understand it um
today I have both good news and bad news
about the changing environment and the
health the good news is that on a
national and a state level our citizens
have adapted well to the Extremes in
heat and precipitation even as climate
warm Society has been able to reduce
heat related deaths by over uh uh
significantly over the past 50 years
cutting the death risk of death in half
in our
cities that's as the the the uh uh
conditions in the planet continue to
warm in addition we've been able ble to
improve air quality and reduce related
deaths by over $100,000 a year you heard
that mention 100,000 people per year uh
deaths these are improvements you rarely
hear about in the media or from ad
advocacy groups I believe we need to
teach our children and youth um I should
say citizens and youth about the past
successes if they're have hope and kindy
insights on how we're going to address
and solve these larger issues of climate
change um the bad news about um climate
is rapidly warming it's causing
disruptions in our environment and our
economy um it's unbalancing our
ecosystems and it's threatening our
health we can and will adapt to changes
in our own state yet mitigating the
global causes will require significant
diplomatic effort Investments free
market Innovations and international
cooperation um no matter how much this
nation reduces it fossil fuels or invest
in new technology we cannot spend or
legislate our way out of this situation
on our own
as introduced HR 27 would direct the
legislator to support all relevant data
and perspectives on climate policy yet
how will you do this as individuals and
as committees each year there are up to
50,000 new studies related to weather
climate and Earth Sciences of these at
least a thousand make it into the main
three media sources that gain public
attention in order to assess which study
is relevant or unbiased you'll need to
trust someone to interpret that
information for you I would propose that
this legislative body work together in a
bipartisan way to develop guidelines for
this challenging task first there's a
need to identify the best information
from the least bi sources who will
assess them here I encourage you to find
engage with and support the New
Hampshire State programs um state
agencies that and the people who are
dedicated both the climate science and
to ongoing critique of that there there
is some settled science yet many gaps
and knowledges uh knowledge to explore
second there's a need to develop
competencies for teaching differences
between weather climate n and their
natural and human influences to set a
via a set of critical thinking Concepts
and skills our schools and yours your
universities I believe would do
currently doing a fair job of teach
teaching critical thinking and feeling
skills in closing I believe this is a
good starting point to provide both the
legislative and executive branches with
clear concise and evidence-based
information that will allow you to make
the sound decisions about weather
climate and health policy thank you for
for allowing me the opportunity to speak
today will you take any questions I'm
happy to take questions yes
representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my
question isn't climate change term
that's being used cyclical has it not
happened in the past even before man was
on this planet and where we might have
had uh frozen tundra that it you'd have
palm trees A Thousand Years
Later the way I describe it to my
students when I'm teaching is that yes
climate has had a lot of variability and
is a and over time what we're seeing
differently now is the rate of change it
is increasing much more rapidly than it
has in the past and because of our
Advanced scientific understanding we can
that to certain both natural and human
influences but we're very clear about
the the human
influences any further
questions seeing none thank you sir
thank you very well presented appreciate
it and I have one more C just came in
Julius
soti
representative
Julius good morning honorable members of
the
committee I came here in support of U HR
27 and I was com felt compelled to come
here to speak because I really hate when
science is used to lie cheat and
exaggerate and I come at this position
from the perspective of a philosopher of
Science and epistemology
epistemology is the theory of knowledge
in the theory of
knowledge you go you try to figure out
how do you know that you know now I'm
not going to take this to the extreme
position of like dayart I think
therefore I am or Socrates all that I
know is that I know nothing but uh
there's a level of humil there that's
missing in many of our PhD scientists I
mean PhD is a doctor of philosophy and
they're um not doing the philosophy
they're not doing the more rigorous
certainty thinking here now inep in
epistemology you learn that there's
degrees of certainty and that there's an
anatomy to knowledge now there two types
of knowledge
essentially what's called a prior
knowledge
which is reason derived from thought
logic and math 2 * 2 equals four that's
high
certainty and then there's empirical
knowledge which is experimental and
observational lower
certainty experimental studies they have
variables increased complexity certainty
drops off exponentially at this point
most scientific studies end up being
wrong in the end and contradict each
other
science looks for uh predictive value
and certainty and that's where we come
to the climate issue and my professor
used to say um if you can't make the
prediction you're wrong get back to the
drawing board and there is a spectrum of
certainty in
science there are there are
um predictive
sciences and it goes towards descriptive
Sciences which don't predict anything it
tells you what is and they make
extrapolations and well good luck with
anything after that and an example of u
a predictive science would be um in
physics and chemistry using mostly a
prior knowledge of logic and math mixing
element a with element B explosion
happens simple
now as the variables
increase your certainty drops off and
then throughout different Sciences your
variables are increasing exponentially
biology psychology sociology economics
climatology
Evolution now in
evolution they're not going to tell you
anything about where we're going they'll
tell you where we've been but not where
we're
going economics
again um if eon economists were any good
at predicting they'd all be
multi-millionaires and the same goes for
uh climate
science it's the best that they could do
is
extrapolate and they have ex
extrapolated global
warming and they've turned it into a
revenue stream through fear-mongering
and fearmongering cells gets funding
creates some funding bias everything is
connected to it and it corrupts the
science which brings us to the bill um
consider all relevant information much
information is
ignored and not properly
reviewed it doesn't fit the
narrative I have an
example the uh there's a the nicolov
Zeller study it's a they came up with a
mathematical model that predicts
accurately predicts Global mean surface
temperatures of rocky planets and moons
in the solar system including the Earth
in a nutshell what they came up with is
atmospheric
pressure and Atmospheric density are the
climate drivers you have Venus which is
very thin
atmosphere and very cold Venus which was
always the analog for the greenhouse
story is 90 times greater pressure than
the
earth and is extremely
hot so so the analogy would be a thick
blanket versus a thin
blanket and this incidentally This
research is also Beed out by uh
NASA they have What's called the Havoc
program uh it's the High Altitude Venus
o uh operational concept they have a
plan to send people to
Venus but obviously they wouldn't be
able to be on the surface with the
surface pressure and heat being so
extreme they envisioned a um
floating vessel about 50 km up in the
atmosphere where the density is similar
to Earth and so is the temperature
despite the 96% carbon dioxide versus
a minuscule percent
on Earth again pointing to
the density being the
key
so finally I do want to point out
another thing if we
ever come up with a carbon tax and
codify it into our Revenue stream we
could just forget about getting
anything about the truth in this matter
I'll answer any
questions we have any
questions
seeing none thank you representative
taking the time to come here today and I
will now close the hearing on HR 27 and
turn the gavl over to its right
pona thank you representative when you
say rightful owner my name is is on this
gal now I don't you mention it uh thank
you for willing it for us here and
moving on to the next scheduled uh
measure hr26 urging Congress to adopt a
constitutional amendment to distinguish
between corporate and individual rights
that is
hr26 uh representative n is is the uh
Prime the prime sponsor she is in the
house and we're very pleased to welcome
the prime sponsor to uh introduce hr26
welcome representative thank you thank
you Mr chair and thank you to the
members of the committee for uh taking
you uh your time and consideration this
morning so what we have is um a call on
Congress to propose an amendment that
clarifies that corporations are not
endowed with the same um constitutional
rights as individual um living breathing
human beings seems pretty obvious to me
but we have uh precedent based on
precedent built on precedent where the
Supreme Court has ruled essentially that
they are entitled to the same rights one
thing I thought was really interesting
that I wanted to uh show you today
um and now I can't find it okay um was
that there was a market change so there
were rules uh there were rulings in the
first place the Supreme Court made
rulings that did clarify and they did
say in their summary that uh that uh
corporations were not end endowed with
the same rights but along the way we
have changed this essentially coming
from uh way back to the railroads I
believe that was in the 1850s um there
was precedent that uh put them on the
same footing as whatever so what I'd
really like to clarify is the logic of
this if we're really looking at what the
logic um ends up being at the end of the
day with our rights come
responsibilities so we are endowed with
these rights but they also come with
responsibilities because if we live in a
society then we all need to we all also
have the respons responsibility not to
infringe on other people's rights that's
what comes along with having these
rights and these rights being insured
and as a society how we ensure that
these rights are maintained and that
everyone's rights are are protected is
uh we have accountability for that so if
you infringe on someone else's rights
then you have accountability that comes
along with it um and so what I really
wanted to do was kind of personalize
this in a way and and really just kind
of deconstruct this argument because um
I know personally and I think a lot of
us are are well aware of the situ ation
with for example um Purdue Pharma Purdue
Pharma infringed on people's rights by
lying outright malicious actions this is
something that they did that infringed
on our rights as human beings yet at the
end of the day I mean it sounds really
silly right to say is uh is this
Corporation in jail has their Liberty
been taken away have they had the same
accountability that an individual would
have if they transgressed on someone
else's rights of course not you can't
put a corporation in jail it's a limited
liability Corporation for a reason and
that makes sense in certain context but
as far as having the rights that we are
entitled to uh within our constitution
as laid out in our constitution it
logically does not make sense for them
to have the same rights if they do not
have the same responsibilities and the
same accountability I.E taking away
their individual freedom and individual
liberty so that's my argument um the
reason why it needs to be a
constitutional amendment is because we
do have this precedent on Supreme Court
rulings where somewhere along the line
there was a rational rationalization
that made the comparison and said they
they are uh equal to people and then
there was another ruling and then there
was another ruling and and precedent
upon precedent upon precedent has put us
in this place we have Constitutional
Amendments for a reason to either say
yeah maybe we were wrong on that let's
correct this maybe we needed to include
more people expand these protections um
and also to clarify things so what this
is is essentially clarifying that
corporations are not entitled to the
same rights as an
individual uh would be in the society
and therefore it is okay for us to uh to
uh to curb their privileges in certain
ways I.E spending in political
campaigns I think that's that's
basically it um I'm happy to answer any
questions thank you representative uh
the notion that money is speech um it's
been out there a lot and in the wording
in your resolution specifically says
money is not speech uh I'm trying to
remember maybe some of the other members
of the committee can member uh money
being speech is you mentioned the
Supreme Court precedence the where did
that come from the notion that money is
speech that's out there right yeah
actually I do have an expert here uh Sam
Feldman and he can speak much better to
um the the process of how the precedent
has been laid out essentially it started
with corporate personhood and then based
on corporate personhood that you say
okay well then what rights are they
entitled to if they're equal to a person
um Sam can lay it out much better I I
promise okay uh other
questions citizens united is what I'm
I'm sorry I don't want to speak out of
turn uh go go ahead representative
citizens united is the latest one uh
people kind of say it opens the flood
gate but it's not the first it really
goes back to Citizens United is based on
other precedent that has been in Supreme
Court ruling so it's really kind of this
this morphing overtime um I believe the
the first one was the railroads back in
1850 something out in California um and
that was the the argument then that was
the initial personhood argument and then
it's just kind of built on based on
here's this rationalization that we
provided in this which is a a Supreme
Court ruling which is precedent so then
it's considered in the next one so it
kind of uh it builds on itself and it's
gotten to the point where it kind of
morphs into uh what we have
today other questions representative
shli thank you thank you for being with
us today I was just wondering if you've
spoken to any of the four members of
Congress from New Hampshire about filing
a constitutional amendment and if so
what was their response actually we just
recently had something very similar um
HR I mean Haj resolution 54 this is a
joint resolution we do have our members
of Congress are are on board to a to a
degree it's not exactly the same
language um but they are trying to to
kind of get to the same effect uh this
is making the point this is encouraging
them I understand this is non-binding
this is uh really a statement of this is
what we'd really like you to do and they
are already doing it I feel like this is
um this is clarifying exactly what we
would like to be in that that Amendment
and what we'd like to address with it
you know what what our intent
is
other
questions seeing none uh thank you
representative representative n uh Sam
fieldman is here he's been here before
welcome back Sam uh he's asked for three
minutes to amplify a little bit on uh
representative n's measure uh
representing Wolfpack uh welcome back
Sam thank you Mr chair thank you members
of the committee my name is Sam fieldman
with Wolfpack um when Wolfpack first
formed part of why it Formed um there
was already an existing group moved to
amend that was working on resolutions
very much like this one and moved to
amend at the time opposed the Article 5
convention route Wolfpack was formed
partially in response to that to make
sure that there was a group pushing for
the Article 5 convention route like hjr
9 that this committee passed uh just
recently um both groups have since
changed their position to some degree
moved to amend has since embrace the
idea of resolutions like hj9 that passed
recently and Wolfpack has also seen the
additional separate value in in passing
resolutions like this one here they
should not be considered in competition
with each other they should both pass um
and the best example of why we saw in
the 17th Amendment uh it's not certainly
not the only example the Bill of Rights
is an example the um uh repeal of
prohibition is an example but um in uh
the 17th Amendment uh there was a strong
push for an article 5 convention effort
to uh to get direct election of senators
and that worked side by side with a
number of other political efforts to
change public opinion to send messages
to Congress to actually propose direct
election themselves and that's why once
we got to the point where we were very
close to the number of states that we
needed to call a convention within one
or two um the O un other underlying
political work uh to push Congress had
gotten to to the point where they were
able to use that leverage to get over
the hump and that's how these two ideas
work hand inand together um I do also
want to say a word about the uh the
language here corporations are not
people and money is not speech Wolfpack
doesn't usually use those terms but
other groups do and we do not uh have
any problem with groups using those
terms uh I myself have have used them um
individually many times um the the first
case the cases that deal with corporate
personhood uh date back to the to the
1800s um and for a very long time you
can see cases where rights were granted
to
corporations that made sense for
corporations to have as standin for
individual human rights uh rights of
actual people are guaranteed by the
Constitution there are some rights like
the right to contract the right to sue
and be sued things like that where um
you need to have in order for humans to
exercise those rights the corporations
that they own must also exercise those
rights but it should never be confused
with the idea of the corporation itself
having rights corporations are not
people corporations are liability
Shields if you treat a corporation as
identical to yourself you literally lose
the corporation it dissolves you lose
the liability Shield it it simply is not
um identical with the human who owns it
it's not it's by law not allowed to be
treated as such um and then when we saw
in the case of Bot
uh the First National Bank of
Boston uh there was a great dissent
there written by Justice ranquist who
listed all of the times that
corporations had been granted uh
personhood rights in the US Constitution
this is in
1978 um and he noted in in that case uh
well first of all it was clear in that
case that all of those could be
justified As Natural extensions of the
rights of actual humans not rights given
directly to the corporation having the
corporation have their own Rights was
not necess necessary for any of those
and then he noted that the extension of
that which was what was what happened in
that case to political rights as a
separate entity for the corporation was
highly dangerous and completely
unprecedented uh with respect to um
anything that had come before that uh
and we've seen that play out and magnify
with cases like citizens united that
came around later also in answer to to
your question the the case that uh
initially claimed that um that money is
speed as opposed to a tool for speech uh
was two years before that it was um
I Buckle V valo in
1976 um and up until that point the idea
was that money is a tool for speech just
like a bullhorn as a tool for speech
you're not and there's limits on how you
can use it you can't take a bullhorn to
a polling place and tell people how to
vote just like in uh in some states
people literally buy up all of the
advertising airtime and drown out all
other messages that is incompatible with
the Free Speech rights of actual humans
to use that tool in excess um the
limitations that we always have on on
speech are uh that you can have uh
limited reasonable content neutral
restrictions on time place and manner uh
if the Restriction is unreasonable that
would be unconstitutional if it's
content based that's also uncons ution
uh it can only be a limit on how much
money you can spend under certain
circumstances to make sure that people
are still able to exercise their speech
but not in such a way that it drowns out
other speech uh and that's that's always
been the Constitutional test up until
Buckle V valo and up until Botti and
that's what the Constitutional test
should still be thank
you thank you m fieldman questions
anything
else seeing No Hands uh Sam thank you
for your uh your testimony thank you and
I have no more pink cards on
hr20
six so that at this
time I will close the hearing on HR
26 that that brings us
hr23
hr23 is a resolution calling for the New
Hampshire Congressional Delegation to
support a national universal health
insurance
program so I have a lot of uh Pink cards
here um which I'm not surprised that
this uh healthc care is uh certainly
important to everyone the prime sponsor
representative L monang is is here uh
welcome uh representative and you can
have uh as much time as you need as a
prime sponsor uh for this important
resolution uh given the the Vol the
great number of pink cards uh I'm
looking at some requests for five
minutes 10 minutes um I really want to
uh one person asked for 2.5 minutes so
they have that measured down to two and
a half minutes uh so we let the prime
sponsor have whatever time she needs to
thoroughly uh introduce this resolution
and thank you for the uh handouts so
those that follow uh I I don't want to
have a strict uh limit to your your
speech speaking of speech from our last
resolution but I would ask that uh if if
some points have been made that uh that
you don't feel a need to repeat or
reiterate uh information that we've
already heard uh always looking for new
uh new
information uh represent mon
welcome well thank you Mr chairperson
and members of the committee for letting
me speak today um and I will try to keep
it brief it's hard it's a long
resolution um but just a little bit of
my own background I worked for um 15 to
20 years in in various forms of Public
Health Nutrition and my last um job in
that field I was a wick director for two
counties in North Carolina and our
clinics were all located in in either
County Public Health offices or
Community um health organizations
nonprofits whose mission it was was to
serve uh uninsured and underinsured
people in the community and as
organizations they were just barely able
to scrape enough money up through some
Medicaid self-pay and some grants to
operate and we couldn't even afford to
provide health insurance for our own
employees um so we were on our own and
in my other career I work in um
residential home construction so I know
what it's like to have to buy health
insurance on your own not through your
employer so about this resolution let me
be clear that this is not socialized
medicine uh we're talking about a
single-payer managed system that is n
National and publicly um
managed we already have Single Payer
Health um in systems in this country
like
Medicare or Tri care they are single
pair they're just not Universal and
that's what we're looking
for um and it's our current system is
tremendously expensive and
inefficient and by freeing ourselves
from this very very complicated system
of private insurance it really would be
a boon
for doctors to be able to open their own
practice again like we haven't seen in
decades and this would be very helpful
to rural areas because one of the
biggest problems is that a medical
practice has to have a team of Staff
people whose sole job is to try to
negotiate with insurance companies all
day
long
so we we also don't have you know moving
on to the second point of my resolution
we don't have Universal coverage there's
still a lot of people that lack health
insurance in this country about 25
million and even those that have
insurance have high barriers such as
deductibles and restrictive networks of
what what doctors they can go
to we have the most expensive healthc
care in the world and really the worst
outcomes of of any developed
country and we have major gaps in our
insurance
system that's particularly for dental
care and for long-term care and for me
that's one of the the most criminal
aspects of our system is that if you're
not lucky enough to die in your sleep
peacefully in your late 80s and you end
up needing long-term care for any length
of time if you're not a rich person very
much you will deplete all of your assets
leaving nothing for your children and go
on Medicaid at the end of your life this
is what happens to Working Families
middle class families all over New
Hampshire and the country and the reason
for that is we don't have National
long-term
care and another big problem with our
private insurance system is
that there it's really an impediment for
people seeking preventive care with high
deductibles and so people delay getting
care for chronic mental conditions and
end up going to the ER instead of a
primary care
doctor and we all know this is a huge um
cost to hospitals and for our system
functioning
efficiently and I we have several
doctors that can speak more to the
effects on their own
practices but another big area is um
what high medical costs do to Americans
um
financially 20% of Americans report that
it's difficult to pay their medical
bills and 66% of all bankruptcies in the
United States are due to medical
bills that's enormous
another big reason that I am in favor of
a national universal health insurance
program is having Insurance that's
independent of your job will allow
people to pursue happiness in the job
that they love not just the job with
health
benefits personal freedom is one of the
biggest reasons I'm in favor of a
national health insurance
system um just think what it would mean
for people that want to start their own
business and already have to come up
with a lot of money but then to have to
pay for health insurance for all their
employees it's a daunting thing it would
be a great freedom for small businesses
and entrepreneurs and let alone the big
manufacturing companies that have to
compete with businesses from other
countries where those businesses don't
have to pay for insurance for their
employees it's already paid for so
that's a huge economic disadvantage for
American businesses that are competing
internationally and another big group
are um having an insurance program for
everyone it would help gig workers who
do not get benefits in their job and
they're an increasingly large part of
our
Workforce they could get insurance
um as easily as their social security
card but let's be be clear we do not
have a free market and health insurance
in this
country if you get coverage through your
job your employer is the one who picks a
plan not you if you buy through the
marketplace which I do now you really
only have one or two options and then
when you look at what um you know on the
marketplace when I first signed up there
were two different plans so I I went
with one and and then after a couple
years thought well maybe I should try
this other one might it might save a
little bit of money on my premium and
then I found that none of the none of my
doctors were on that other plan you know
I really had to go with that one
insurance company who was had the main
Network where I live so I had no
choice and then you know the
plans they this array of plan options
but they all amount to the same thing
you either pay more in
premiums or have a higher deductible and
you end up making you know spending
about the same much amount of
money and another really important
reason for me to have a national
universal health insurance plan is to
eliminate the need for poverty only
government health insurance mainly
Medicaid and I don't want to anyone to
leave here thinking I want to stop the
Medicaid Program only if we have another
option in place because it's the only
option for so many millions of
people but
Medicaid it's has enormous
administrative
costs both you know to qualify People
based on their income and then you have
to do it over and over and over again
and it's also tedious to be on the other
side of that to have to apply for
that and also the stigma of having
Insurance that's only for poor
people when I first applied for um to be
on the exchange through the Affordable
Care Act uh our business had been
decimated by the recession our income
was really low and they told me I had to
apply for Medicaid first and my reaction
I was kind of mortified like I I have
never been on any kind of Public
Assistance in my life and I thought I
don't I don't want to have a Medicaid
card I know what that would be like when
I go to the doctor's
office and I was fortunately I made just
enough money that I didn't have to do
that um and it's also it's a literal
barrier to access because me many
private practices will simply not take
you if if Medicaid is your only
Insurance the other thing is Medicaid is
a disincentive to work if you're at
this position with your income like oh
if I if I make just a little bit more
I'm going to lose my health insurance
and I'm pregnant like I can't do that
I'm going to cut back my hours in order
to qualify or I'm going to work under
the table so that I don't know that I
make a little too much to qualify for
Medicaid and there are so many lower
wage jobs in which the employer gets out
of the responsibility to private to to
provide in Insurance like they say oh it
can only offer you 29 hours a week or
that's why you have many people that are
working more than one job but they still
don't get
insurance
and you know and also Medicaid expansion
while I'm in favor of it in many ways it
uses taxpayer money to subsidize big
employers who find these loopholes
loopholes of not paying their own
employees the
insurance and Medicaid puts half the
burden on States setting up constant
battles in state
legislatures and creating disparities in
health care from state to
state
and a big reason we need the National
Health Plan is the economy of scale we
can't fix this in New Hampshire we're
not big enough to have our own
single-payer Health Care
system and finally I think the most
important at all is
understanding
that we are probably the only country in
the world that has um a low-risk Health
Insurance Pool and a highrisk Health
Insurance
Pool we already have 35% of our
Americans on some type of government
insurance but government spending on
Health Care accounts for
64% of Total Health Care expenditures so
why is that if they're only covering
35% why I have do they have really twice
that much of a share of expenditures
that's because that
35% represents the highrisk pool right
the government government is
ensuring uh all the Indigent anyone with
a
disability any child born with a major
medical problem goes on the chip
program and most important of all all
the
seniors the ones that are most that need
the most health care and have the most
um long-term expensive Health Care needs
the government pays for them and
meanwhile the private insurance
companies like oh you can Ure the
healthy work adult and their children
very few of them are going to have my
high medical
expenses so it's it's set up this system
where they get to make enormous profits
ensuring a low risk pool and the
government picks up the
rest so how is this
sustainable and people uh when I talked
to them about universal healthcare they
said well you know that sounds great but
how can we afford it but really how how
can we afford not to do that how can we
afford not to combine the risk pools
pools like every other country in the
world if we did
that instead of private insurance making
enormous profits of the the lowrisk pool
we could have enough money for Medicare
not to need any
supplements from Medicare to include
dental care and from Medicare to include
long-term care insurance so we can
actually take care of our elderly in a
dignified
way and so I urge you to vote uh to pass
on this resolution it will cost us
nothing it will save us all money if it
actually goes
anywhere but we do want to send a
message to Congress that we need a real
solution
and it has to be
National and I say this to members of my
own party that I want them to do
more as well as the other
party
so uh I'm welcome to take any
questions thank you so much
representative uh I have a couple quick
ones um so
Massachusetts uh famously supposedly uh
a few years ago developed a near
Universal State health care plan um What
If This Were to move forward C can you
speak very briefly at all
about what would that how would that
impact existing state plans that are
near Universal or near Universal yeah
well the the Massachusetts plan is
really it's much like um what we have at
the federal level already in terms of um
it
guarantee you know it's a mixture of
public and private right there are some
you know people don't qualify Medicare
they can get on Mass health which it
covers a certain another point but you
know one of the aspects of the
Affordable Care Act while there are many
good things that I like about it is it
also relies on um subsidies so if you if
you don't if you make too much to qualif
for some of these other federally
managed programs but not quite enough to
F the pay the full
premium the government basically writes
a check to the private insurance company
to fill the Gap in that premium I I
don't like that at all I mean it's just
making the situation worse another
proposal that is often heard like well
let's just open up Medicare for people
55 to
65 that would actually make the
disparities worse it would put more
people that are hired to
insure um on the government Dole and
taking less off the private risk pool
right it'll make it worse it's got to be
Universal and then we could do away with
some of these programs that are
inefficient to
run thank you for that my my other
question uh as most everyone knows our
country is being inundated not New
Hampshire as much as other places with
uh migrants uh here uh coming into the
country illegally and and uh my question
is we're talking about millions and
millions of undocumented folks and I
know uh current Law requires emergency
rooms to take care of people who show up
looking for health care but would your
do you envision your National universal
health insurance program H how would
would illegal or undocumented uh
migrants that type of uh those types of
folks would they be covered by the plan
that you
envision well if they're working
jobs um and paying if they're getting a
paycheck then yes they would probably be
contributing as well as receiving just
like now many illegal workers are
working with illegal Social Security
numbers and they're paying into the
Social Security System unfortunately
they'll probably never be able to
collect on that benefit cuz in the end
they'll be found out an illegal card but
ideally we live in a system where uh
anyone that's working um can be
recognized for working and and and if
they're paying into it they should get
the benefits as well so what I'm hearing
is that if they're not working they
would not be covered is that fair to say
well no because
um the social security number is is
basically
um you have one whether you're working
or not right even if you don't have a
job you might still be eligible Social
Security benefits depending on your
circumstances but how I Envision
Medicare We already pay a Medicare
deduction right for the future that's
which like around 2 and a half or 3% of
our paycheck right and I how I Envision
expanding making Medicare
Universal is you increase that just by a
couple percentage points and that would
be enough Medicare the administrative
cost of Medicare now is only about
3% compared to what you pay for private
insurance you're paying anywhere to 12
to 20% of your paycheck for private
insurance so what I'm saying is you you
pay you're paying in if you have a job
you're not if you don't don't but as
long as you have that number you do but
unlike um Medicaid there's actually no
disincentive to work right the more you
work great you know you're paying a
little bit more but only as a
percentage thank you for that uh other
questions representative
gagy thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question I'm going to be 80
years old in a couple of days I have
haven't worked since
2006 retired from the Postal
Service my health insurance that I pay
the government does not pay my health
insurance takes up half my annuity I'm
happy with that because I don't I'm not
being I'm 80 years old I'm not working
suppose someone who's 40 years old and
is working and paying into the system
right and I have the same condition that
person has the same condition but he's
that individual is still able to work
would that be something like managed
care where if the money is tight
government wise that uh maybe uh someone
like me would be pushed aside down the
road that happened in Canada I know from
my relatives point that the older people
waited like a year to a year and a half
before they were seen some of them died
whereas the working people were seen
first with do you envision perhaps a
possible scenario that
[Music]
way not really I think one one thing is
having a national program will give us
the scale that we can set up um policies
that work for everybody and and I
believe we have enough resources in this
country that we don't have to
deny people
coverage but you know it seems to me
that what we call Managed Care Now is
mostly insurance companies trying to
deny claims and coverage in order to
maximize
profits that's what the private
insurance companies call Managed Care
but I think if it's a publicly run
program with independent panels to
determine best quality of care and
priorities that wouldn't that wouldn't
be the the main motivation for it
it but right now you know my husband's
doctor just retired after being his
doctor for about 40 years and he had to
find a new primary care we spent about
three months just trying to find a
primary care doctor accepting new
patients and his first Primary Care Appo
appointment is 7 months away so we we
have a problem already I hope we can fix
it other questions representative masso
thank thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative for taking my question um
could you clarify the difference between
Universal um health care and socialized
healthare yes socialized medicine is
really uh in which the government is
actually running the health care
facilities that's not the case the only
thing that comes close to that in this
country is the VA where that's a
government government Managed Health
Service um what we're talking about here
is the only the insurance aspect of
it who's paying for that it's you can go
to any doctor with
Medicare good question and good answer I
think representative
Manion thank you uh Mr chair thanks for
taking my question so uh during the
pandemic and after there was a lot of
push especially from in heads at night
late night shows where they were saying
um if you refuse to get the jab you
shouldn't be allowed to have health care
uh would you uh oppose any kind of
measure like that that may be appended
to some kind of universal Medicare or
would you say that someone has the right
to not get vaccinated and continue to
get
care um I probably would not support
that even though I believe vaccines are
good but I do think
um depending on on the stage of an
epidemic um it's certainly um I think
the right of any practice to say no you
must be vaccinated to not put their own
people and other patients at risk but
that's
not perhaps one of the Physicians that
are speaking may may better answer that
question other
questions seeing n thank you so much uh
ma Madam Prime sponsor representative L
monang thank you I have representative
howand um from Durham who's representing
himself supporting the bill asked for up
to three minutes rep represent Howen
welcome thank you Mr chair committee
members for listening to me I'll try to
be really succinct uh before I became a
representative I spent a decade on the
Oyster River School Board and also on
the durm toown council and my major
capacity I worked on the budget
committee and I worked on uh negotiating
with our collective bargaining units and
because we're really personnal driven
health care costs have a huge impact on
us and what we were really looking for
is the ability to stabilize our health
care costs which everybody is trying to
do uh and it really really is
challenging um this year for example uh
deep in our budget process you find out
from the the insurance companies what
your guaranteed maximum is and so this
year at the end of October we found out
it's
15% that's a that's a million doll
impact on our budget that we have two
months to figure out how to come up with
that before we do our public hearing and
it directly impacts of course the tax
impact our our our residents are going
to feel and then that impacts whether
they'll vote for our budget and so we we
tried everything uh we tried working
with different higher deductible plans
for our younger workers and giving them
uh Health uh benefit cards to offset
their co-pays we tried steering them to
Price shopping so that they could get
the best rate on MRIs or blood work or
anything else to stabilize our costs we
tried to have them participate in health
um Healthy Living uh programs to try to
lower their risk and and none of it
works and I think it was touched on on
by the prime sponsor it's because the
pool our pool is too small we couldn't
mitigate the risk and so there's no
ability despite trying our best to be
able to control our costs and so uh the
state faces the same problem we come to
you and say can you please help us we
need to stabilize our costs what can you
do to help us and then New Hampshire
runs into the same problem we did their
pool is too small you can't mitigate the
risk you're also dealing with impact of
Health Care cost on your budget and so
that's why we're asking for or that's
why I support the resolution a national
program broadens our pool and not only
helps the state but helps our
municipalities and our businesses so
that's the reason I support the uh bill
and I I hope I came in under my three
minutes very well presented
representative
questions uh Ron
carry so based on your experience do you
believe because New Hampshire is the
second oldest state in the United States
that our costs are higher as a result of
us being an aging
population thank you for the question I
do and in fact that was part of our
strategy our strategy was our younger
workers if we put them on a higher
deductible then it lowed the cost of
their premiums and we could then make up
for the cost of our older workers who
were more costly it doesn't work the
pool was still too
small another good question and good
answer any other
questions seeing none thank you
representative thank you uh The
Honorable Jen coffee from Manchester is
she here looks like uh someone's heading
up welcome uh former representative of
coffee from
Manchester
supporting the
bill the
resolution thank you I'm not used to
mics being here uh greetings and thank
you for taking the time for this Mr
chairman and honorable members of this
committee I am a former rep and when I
was here I won't I was a republic
and I was vice chair of Commerce and
consumer affairs and for 20 years of my
life I served my community as an EMT and
as a medical technician in
hospital I truly believe that we could
fix healthc care I believed in creating
Health Care compacts and proper
government controls to ensure that the
basics were covered there was a level of
expectation that I had that insurance
would
cover I was blind to the real reties of
what happens when you're the one who
gets sick I learned the hard way and I'd
like to ask you not to support forcing
others to do the same and pass this
resolution sending a clear message to
the hill that we need
change health insurance is the best scam
in America they make money off the sick
and the Dying by denying and delaying
care I've seen patients denied chemo
because the insurance wanted them to try
a different Cho
first and the cheaper one didn't work
and by the time they knew that it was
too late to give them the one that might
have I hugged a daughter of a college
professor who was forced to watch her
father pass as he was denied access to
the very care that could have given him
more time and isn't that what we all
want time health insurance companies
trade our time for their
sailboats this body can tell Congress to
end the fleecing of America Medicare
premiums end up in profit margins while
people die and suffer denied access to
life-saving care did you know that
private for profit insurance companies
collect over $140 billion dollar in
medicare premiums and
overpayments every
year just on their Medicare products
never mind the private insurance
products that they
sell and uh they won't give your
grandmother any teeth she can have puree
a child goes without a athetic that
works for a cheaper one
instead I've taken my struggles publicly
to access the care that I need to stay
alive I had to fight United Healthcare
in the press and in the social media I
had to shame them into talking to me I
had to go to Washington DC and have
meetings and press conferences I met
with senior AIDS and federal of our
federal delegation and they've had to
help me get
coverage I've had to fight for for every
single treatment to stay alive and it's
exhausting forgive
me I want more quality moments in
life isn't that what you want to to have
a life worth
living it's a constant Terror to worry
about access to care I'm one of many
whose cost of living was exacerbated at
the end of the pandemic when our rent
was raised $400 all at once and we were
told to vacate or pay within
two I had to start rationing my
infusions and I still do that
today I get to ration them a little less
when United Healthcare pays at least
part of the
cost you know they boasted 8 billion do
in first quar of profits last year while
they refused to pay $600 for my
infusion let me explain expl something I
have CRPS complex regional pain syndrome
it is the most painful disease known to
modern medicine it has no cure and in
the United States there is no approved
treatment and the fact that the FDA has
failed to approve a treatment has
actually caused my insurance company to
use as an excuse to not cover my care so
if I don't pay nobody
does they don't make money if they pay
for my health care
in fact I would challenge you to tell me
one thing that health insurance does to
increase positive medical outcomes in
any medical
situation National handcuff National
healthc care would grant us true medical
Freedom it would enable everyone to
access the same Health Care currently
limited to the rich and the Pampered and
Powerful Elite with the removal of
insurance companies more people would
live more importantly they would live
longer and with quality a life worth
living this resolution is the will of
the people and we are hoping that you
hear us we are tired of insurance
companies forcing our loved ones to
suffer and die while a life could have
been saved If Only They had not been
denied access to care I had the chance
to travel to the Netherlands and
experience National Health Care
firsthand I was even able to access some
care with a modest out of pocket the
point is that everyone has access no one
is denied medication is given when the
doctor orders
it as it should be I'm asking you to
send a message and pass hr23 and tell
the hill it's time for a change thank
you for your time and um representative
mford I couldn't help but notice your
comment about Massachusetts my parents
still Republicans living in
Massachusetts are hate Romney care it
has caused my mother to suffer it's
caused her to have delays in care and it
couldn't it didn't have to be that way
but Romney care made it
so thank you for that and for uh
addressing that question that I I posed
earlier and thank you for sharing and
and
personalizing uh
questions all right ripson
shli thank you Mr chairman it's not
really a question it's just a comment to
uh representative cofy I think the last
time I saw her was about 15 years ago
when I chaired the house criminal
justice committee and she brought in a
bill to legalize switchblades which the
whole committee was against when she
finished we passed her a bill
unanimously and it's now legal to have a
switchblade and I just want her to know
you was still missed here in the New
Hampshire house and thank you for being
thank you representative schliff and I
was honored that you are actually one of
the co-sponsors for me with some of my
efforts as in with healthc care it was a
situation where bipartisan work was very
well done and this committee has the
ability to do just that now thank you
very interesting other
questions seean thank you
again next I have here uh Dr Marosa
Santiago uh MD representing the
NH dnhp or P he'll explain that
momentarily in himself he's asked for up
to five minutes and he is or she maros
I'm so uh welcome and thank you for the
handout those are always
appreciated you may not
understand maybe not so much your accent
is my hearing so thank you for the
written
testimony Dr
Santiago and for those who don't have a
handout Dr Santiago is a retired child
psychiatrist who supports
hr23
from Romney well
welcome good
morning uh State Committee of state
federal relations and Veterans Affairs
chair Representative maet members
officers members and my all of my
legislators I am Dr marcosa Santiago a
retired child psychiatrist
and supporting
hr23 I am here to respectfully request
you to vote Yes on
hr23 your help passing this resolution
will give Force to the intent of the
House of
Representatives that the New Hampshire
legislature calls on our federal
Congressional Delegation to pursue and
pass
legislation for a national universal
health insurance program this play is
due to the reality that the New
Hampshire cannot provide Universal
Health Insurance on our
own our multiplayer Health Care system
can be best
described as complex and affordable and
broken
maze that no amount of navigation will
lead to getting satis Factory Medical
Care while in practice I had difficulty
advocating for my patients for mental
health services from multiple insurance
companies carrying an array of
plans now retired that I am happily 83
years old with but with
chronic health conditions I can I say I
was I am a recipient of maybe more
proper a victim of one double billing
two over build
$600 for a 30 minute PCP visit with zero
payment from both tradition
Medicare and
supplemental uh Blue Cross Blue
Shield third one month medicine for my
husband cost
$360 thanks Heavens by passing partly
drug coverage and using the so-called
good RX I don't know where whether
you're aware of that uh cost us only
$30 the problem I encoun Ed personally
are only a few among many others that
you had already heard being mentioned by
the former speakers and by
representative lontan who is the primary
sponsor I will be grateful for your yes
vote on
hr23 again so that our New Hampshire
legislator calls on our federal
delegation Congressional Delegation to
pursue and pass legislation for a
national
universal health insurance program thank
you for meeting with your
constituents and
listening thank you Dr Santiago
questions seeing n thank you again we're
going to go to another m D according to
the cart here uh Dr Kenneth doart or you
can explain this make sure we get the
spelling right uh and he is right up
front uh could for the clerk could you
make sure we get your last name correct
yes dkart that's right my name is uh Dr
Kenneth dkart and thank you chairman
Moffett and
representatives
um and I'm giving testimony um in um um
proposing we move forward with hr23
resolution it's sometimes said that
America that we Americans um always do
the right thing after we've tried
everything
else and our everything else has been
these past 40 years the
privatizing
profetizare those of us with gray hair
we remember Blue Cross Blue Shield which
our parents probably had when we were
kids and was affordable
what's the consequence of this this
deregulation your New Hampshire workers
who have health benefits have shouldered
quadrupling insurance premiums since
quadrupled even while added deductibles
make Affordable Care
impossible New Hampshire
employers scramble to find reasonable
health plans for their employees and
those workers potential salary raises
are siphoned off to cover insurance
coverage for Gig workers as mentioned
and for those families living in poverty
healthc care is fragmented by transient
coverage either on the ACA or Medicaid
both of which the state now contracts
out to manage care companies whose
fiduciary responsibility is to Wall
Street that's their mission they are a
for-profit organization um so as of
January
2024 additionally 15 million Americans
have lost that Medicaid coverage uh that
was due to the lapse of the American
Rescue act adding to the 25 million
Americans who already go without health
insurance so unique to this developed
country Americans create GoFundMe sites
to pay for their Cancer Care or go
bankrupt even if they have insurance
from uncovered medical expenses that is
is the reality didn't used to be that
way as a primary care internist and a
geriatrician uh I've served New
Hampshire patients for 40 years I have
personally witnessed People's Health
destroyed when their medical care is
interrupted by loss of coverage and loss
of their treatments or by arbitrary
denials of service or medication we hear
so much about
rationing the rationing is happening
towards Wall Street towards profit and
who's paying for that we are with our
health the absence of a health
system devoted to health rather than
profit has resulted in preventative and
essential Primary Care becoming ever
harder to find as we all know especially
in rural
areas we Trail the developed world in
the rate of death which would otherwise
be prevented by the way had quality Care
been delivered and that's only one of
numerous dismal metrics which reflect
the absence of a genuine health system
in the United States any semblance of a
systemwide health planning is sacrificed
to short-term corporate profit that's
why the companies exist to make profit
that's fine but it doesn't serve us well
um as a public good of Interest
basically for 60 years by the way
traditional Medicare has excelled in
administrative efficiency and is enabled
exemplary care actually by those Med
metric for seniors and those with kidney
failure and disabilities however even
there a recent
privatization with overly subsidized
contracts to the poorly regulated
intermediary Medicare Advantage
megaliths now threatens the financial
Integrity of Medicare the public dollars
lost as mentioned to fraudulent upcoding
denial and restriction of services and
lucrative contract subsidies would be
better spent improving traditional
Medicare so in National Health Care and
coverage system is really required to
coordinate the availability of
clinicians and eliminate the obvious
pricing failure we're all seeing an
extraordinary administrative waste of
our healthc care
Dollar by the way as a side note um
funding by A Single Payer such as
Medicare does not preclude prevent the
involvement of intermediary
insurers that's common in many other
countries um but what it does require is
adequate regulation and
standardization directed towards
efficient Health Care rather than
diversion towards
profit for the first time since polling
has been done by the way in the United
States a majority of Americans now rate
the quality of US Health Care as only
fair or quote poor that's new in my
lifetime um selecting health insurance
as many of us know if you have health
insurance is a hassle deductibles are
absurd locating a primary care doctor is
difficult if not impossible your medical
care is
fragmented figuring out what medications
are covered by your insurance is
inscrutable for you as the patient and
for me as the doctor that's not by
accident we continue to lack guarantees
of universal
affordable
accessible and high Quality Healthcare
which is enjoyed by the rest of the
developed
World your constituents including lots
of small business owners actually
support this resolution so please uh
support our Congressional
representatives in creating legislation
that will provide affordable accessible
Universal highquality national health
insurance that places the health of New
Hampshire Citizens first thank you thank
you so much for that represent of G will
you take a question represent
gagley thank you Mr chairman thank you
doctor for taking my question I'm going
to be a devil's advocate if that's okay
with
you okay let's say this Universal Health
Care insurance program passes by the way
I have zero co-pay because I'm paying a
whole bunch of money all right uh who
who would be responsible for its
Administration would it be medical
professionals would it be somebody
elected into high office who makes a
decision so can I ask you do you have
Medicare I do right so who is currently
responsible for that the Social Security
Administration this is since 1965 right
and nobody asked me to to nobody asked
me if I wanted money taken out of my
paycheck for Medicare I didn't want it
how do you find um how long have you
been so you you're a you mentioned be 80
Monday all right so you've been on
Medicare since
65 no 62 well no 65 because no Medicare
until you are 65 do you find it
satisfactory having had Medicare I don't
use it doesn't do anything your heal so
your health is good my health well I've
had 13 getting into a kind of
a so I guess what I guess what I'm
saying is you currently have what is the
most favored form of health insurance in
the United States if you look at hmos uh
if you look at proprietary insurance
that existed before hmos Travelers
Metropolitan Health whatnot since the
the the um end of Blue Cross Blue Shield
which was nonprofit Community rated
health
insurance the most popular health
insurance has been consistently Medicare
it has a three why is that it's not
socialized
medicine Medicare has a 3% overhead for
it Administration by the way in 1965
when it was started 19 million people
were enrolled without computers in a
year government can be efficient we've
and it's been demonstrated in that
particular form of single-payer namely
Medicare it's now threatened by um
propati and and over anyhow so so my
question sir is who would be responsible
for its Administration would it be
medical professionals or somebody
elected into office deciding well
there's only going to be so much money
given for this
procedure so you're asking about who
would be responsible for making
decisions about what is covered thank
you okay so so the administration would
would be a government by the way this
doesn't describe the details of what a
universal uh accessible uh um Health
System would look like um but as to who
does the um uh decision it's your doctor
doctor that's what Medicare Does
Medicare will um
essentially cover what CL more so than
private insurance what your clinician
feels that you require that's the nature
of Medicare it is not socialized
medicine the hospitals are not owned by
Medicare or a single-payer system
they're not built by Medicare or
single-payer system they're independent
doctors are independent they make their
medical decisions
independently um um and again you have a
supplement to pay for your Medicare Part
D that's a different story in terms of
drugs guess who's making the decisions
about whose whose drugs are
covered it's not the government it's
your insurance company oh we don't pay
for Jans for your diabetes sorry you
have to do you have to jump through this
hoop then that hoop then this hoop then
maybe we'll pay for the EXP for the more
pricey but more effective medication
that's not the government that's doing
that that's your health health
insurance followup sir followup thank
you thank you again for putting up with
me no no not at all uh they're excellent
questions because uh
okay I have a procedure done at
Dartmouth Hitchcock they charge x amount
of dollars okay it goes to Medicare and
Medicare says no we're not going to pay
that right we're going to pay instead of
uh $2,000 we're going to pay $400 $50 MH
so if I don't have insurance my regular
insurance that I'm paying half my
annuity
for I would have that would be out of
pocket totally agree it's nuts and it's
and unfort that's why people have
GoFundMe um they go on in the internet
because they they didn't have insurance
because there's no Universal Insurance
here unlike anywhere else on Earth in
developed countries or you have
insurance but it's out of network so you
ended up with the only place in in the
in the state can provide your care but
oh well by the way your insurance
company says you're out a
network if you are an investor on Wall
Street you're making big bucks who's
making these decisions it's being made
by uh not by folks who have interest in
in health outcomes um and that's the
difference between Single Payer programs
that are devoted towards Health
versus profit which is what a company
that is in the business to make profits
has to do thank you for that thank you
Doctor another
question sh thank you so much for that
uh enlightened testimony if I say that
Lynn
Brown Lynn is here from lime she is the
individual who asked for two minutes and
30 seconds we won't hold you to that Lyn
thank you for coming to
conquered uh thank you thank you Mr
chairman and to all the members of the
committee um I am speaking in support of
um of of this
resolution um I've never done this
before so this is sort of exciting I
have been a physician since
1979 in New Hampshire I've worked at
dmouth hitchcok Medical Center and at
New London Hospital and I have been
dismayed over my 40 plus years of um
practice here on how increasingly
dysfunctional this system has become
patients with commercial and public
Insurance struggle to pay for health
care and especially those patients
without health insurance high and ever
increasing premiums High deductibles and
co-pays all add up for everyone the cost
of tests and medication are routinely
things that I talk about with my
patients in treating their
arthritis I'm a rheumatologist and I
have had the pleasure of seeing the
treatment of arthritis evolve amazing ly
we have medicines that really can make
people well lead normal lives stop
having um joint Replacements Etc but uh
insurance companies also dictate what
drugs can be used they require
pre-authorization forms which are all
different which take time from me and my
staff and frequently delay treatment for
patients for weeks this
pre-authorization is required every year
or with the the change of insurance and
may even result in people stopping a
drug that's effective because it's no
longer covered by the insurance that
they now have um patients stay in jobs
as you've heard specifically because
they get
insurance I have had patients who are
very well off have insurance have
Medicare have supplemental insurance
have their insur their arthritis is not
well controlled on the medications that
they're currently using I've suggested
that we change those add to it and my
patient has um decided not to take those
medications because even with Medicare
co- Insurance it this is going to cost
her more than $2,000 a month this
shouldn't happen in our great country
there's lots of money as you've heard in
the system but it's siphoned off to
profits and administrative overhead so
often so we need a new F system at the
federal level because all states are
small so I'm asking you to empower our
state representatives and Senators to
support this resolution for national
health coverage for all Americans
through a single pair thank you thank
you two minutes and 30 seconds I was not
I was listening so intently I was not
watching my
watch uh thank you very much seeing no
questions um we're going to look to
someone from your part of the state I
believe from
um uh Etna uh K
hillinger by the way every pink card is
uh signed in in support of the
bill um so obviously including um K
Hiller
welcome thank you Mr
chairman
um good morning to you and to your other
legislators gathered here
today um I have practiced medicine for
years I practiced at Dartmouth Hitchcock
for a number of years and retired from
that
institution 10 years
ago during the years I've been in
practice there have been countless
occasions when I've had patients who
have suffered greatly because of the
lack of affordable accessible Health
Care I've listened to their
concerns about the cost of medical care
for themselves and their loved
ones millions of Americans now are
either uninsured or
underinsured imagine what it would be
like to be in such a situation without
access to health care because of being
able unable to afford the insurance
premiums and the high
deductibles sadly those who lack
coverage often are faced with exorbitant
bills for their care and many will have
to declare
bankruptcy my focus includes those
patients but also those who do have
insurance I have often seen that even
patients who have insurance can suffer
because of the current health insurance
system which is a profit-based
system which pits the need for medically
necessary treatment against the
insurance company's bottom line this
happens all too often I'd like to share
with you a case in
point I had a
patient a woman in her
50s with
insurance who had an imuno deficiency
syndrome and this meant that she lacked
the um imunoglobulin which are proteins
made by the immune system which protect
us
from serious
infections well this woman lacked those
and therefore she needed to receive
intravenous infusions of imunoglobulin
on a monthly basis so that she would not
have recurrent episodes of severe
life-threatening infection which would
lead to
hospitalization and possibly
death when I saw this
patient I ordered immune globuline
infusions for
her our insurance company denied the
infusions they would not pay for
them I made many phone calls to the
insurance company about this issue I
wrote letters
and I even talked to the medical
director of the insurance
company to no
avail finally a colleague of mine who
had seen the
patient in the past as well joined me in
writing a strongly worded letter to the
insurance company stating that if this
patient died as a result of denial of
care that the insurer would bear the
responsibility only after this did the
insurance company agree to approve the
essential treatment for this
patient this is just one example in
which the physician's responsibility for
the patient's Medical Care is balanced
against the insurance company's bottom
line as
legislators you have the opportunity to
make a profound
difference for the people of New
Hampshire and by voting in favor of HR
Bill HR 23 I hope you will vote in favor
um I hope you will talk to your
um Congressional Delegation from the
state of New Hampshire and encourage
them
to vote in favor of a
national Universal Affordable Health
Care system for all people in this
country thank
you thank thank you
Doctor
questions seeing on thanks
again we'll now move on to uh Julie
laari from matury Julie is here here
welcome good morning chairman Moffett
Vice chair rolands committee members
thank you for the opportunity to share
input on this very important issue I'm
here today on behalf of my daughter and
every child who is relying on us to
provide a safer healthier
World there are many explanations as to
why a universal health fund Health Care
Program won't work the American Bar
Association reported that we have a
100-year history of failed attempts to
deliver Universal Health Coverage to
Americans it is daunting at best and
more than challenging work it calls for
large system disruption it calls for
breaking down silos and creating
collaboration between competing
groups and I know we're smart enough to
do the work we just have to care about
the same
things many of the cons to Universal
healthc care are fear-based it's too
expensive it will never work it's never
worked
before there will always be a story of a
failure used as a shiny example of why
Universal Health Care doesn't
work but then I'm REM then I'm reminded
of what leadership
is leaders don't go to the table with
what doesn't work they go to the table
with
Solutions with an entrepreneurial
mindset they focus on what's possible
they innovate they challenge the status
quo they don't let fear sty
progress when we hear people debating
why what the other side of the aisle
wants won't work we often hear
anger yet emotional intelligence
research tells us that anger is almost
always a byproduct of fear
when we hear someone getting upset about
change we know they are experiencing
fear the good news is we can manage our
fears we can replace them with Hope by
focusing on a common goal a common
purpose to unit us a federally funded
Universal healthc Care Program provides
a common goal we are here to make the
world a better place for the generations
that come after US Safety and Security
comes from the knowled that healthc care
is accessible affordable and includes
the whole
person census census.gov reported that
in 2021 3.9 million children didn't have
health insurance that is an egregious
failing and it's still not the full
picture I'd like to share a very quick
story of my family's Journey since
adopting our daughter in 2022 to
highlight that even with private
Insurance we're failing because our
Medical Systems divide mental and
physical health care a divide that
desperately needs to be
addressed we adopted a beautiful bright
intelligent funny 8-year-old and within
a short time realized that her mental
health needs were
extraordinary as was her past
trauma despite having private insurance
and Medicaid because she was in the
foster care system her mental health
needs were not met in New
Hampshire we ultimately enrolled her in
a program in Missouri that helps adopted
children learn how to attach to and
Trust grown-ups we've paid over
$180,000 and the state of New Hampshire
is now covering her costs of
care while I'm grateful she's getting
support it is not a small thing that
instead of enjoying third grade she
spent weeks on end in emergency
departments three different extended
emergency department stays waiting for
stabilization
hospitals between her first two
emergency department stage she went to
Hamstead Hospital the only Psychiatric
Hospital in the state for children and
what we saw there broke our
hearts after 10 days we brought her home
because we were told she wasn't
safe they were overrun with need and are
grossly underresourced
my daughter deserved better
she deserved safe home as an infant and
a young
child and she deserves a Health Care
system that is equipped to meet the
needs of children in
crisis a universal healthc CARE program
that includes mental and physical health
under the same system can create
synergies of collaboration that can make
a real difference for the most
vulnerable we have to do better and I
believe that you can make a real
difference if we use the right language
people will listen if we rally behind a
common goal of protecting families and
children we can find what unites us and
we can disrupt systems for the
better please stand in support of a
federal Universal Health Care program
that couples mental and physical health
under one
system the work is worth it our
communities our families our children
are worth it thank
you thank you for sharing and and
personalizing um
questions not seeing any I do want to
make a quick comment uh when The
Honorable Jen Coffey uh was here in the
past uh preco uh you probably remember
you you me you mentioned that the
microphone was was new uh from your
previous experience I just want to point
out that these uh hearings nowadays are
are recorded uh I check I sometimes go
back and check some of the testimony
myself uh and I noticed that there are
always hundreds hundreds of uh all of
these hearings get uh hundreds sometimes
over a thousand views and they're out
there forever so your uh testimony and
also we have one of the best clerks
maybe the best clerk in the house uh you
should see what she's writing so that
the written testimony the notes that she
takes the YouTube uh recordings um so
your testimony really is heard and and
uh
appreciated all right uh also supporting
the bill as are as I said all the pink
cards are hun Hunter Hobson from
um Seminary
Hill where is Seminary Hill if we could
ask Mr Hobson West leanon West a lot of
folks from uh
greater dmouth hitchock today welcome
thank
you um so I want to say before we start
I consider myself very lucky to be
sitting here talking before you today I
considered myself to be a pretty lucky
person in general I grew up in a good
area house had some issues but we were
able to stay out of trouble for the most
part uh when I was 18 I joined the
Marines and I served Faithfully for five
years Ura
simplify uh
in 2018 I got out and my luck started to
run out a little bit I was in between TR
care and Care at the VA and the mission
act hadn't started yet I got in a
vehicle or not vehicle excuse me a a
motor accident the damage kept me out of
work for several months your visit alone
was about 9
Grand uh but I thought it was nothing I
couldn't handle uh I was able to get an
optometry appointment during my finals
week my first semester back at College
uh and it was there that I had found it
was found that I had a massive retinal
tear that was at risk for total
Detachment uh turns out this condition
is secondary to something I was born
with a condition that is not rare um and
that makes it more likely uh this was
the first time in my life that I felt
the real fear of
bankruptcy I consider myself be unlucky
the VA covered the surgery and the
soonest day that they could do it was
Christmas Eve uh Christmas Day I woke up
from the surgery my eye was covered and
I had the real thought I wonder if this
eye will be blind for the rest of my
life I wonder if it'll happen to the
other eye too will my joints
recover I lay in the bed crippled
physically and emotionally by the fear
of economic
dread luckily again
I continue with PT OT and Continued
Care and I make a pretty substantial
recovery here today um I went on to
become an EMT and then in EKG tech I
worked as both uh during the pandemic in
the height of the pandemic 2020 in the
covid capital of the world at the time
Los
Angeles um and I saw scores of people
whose Hearts took the last beats during
those
months these people didn't work less
than me they didn't want to live less
than me they didn't love their family
less than me they left them all the same
and they left them with hundreds and
thousands millions of dollars in
debt I considered myself lucky the prior
Health complications that I am burdened
with have not taken my life however like
many of you I'm predisposed to
Alzheimer's so we'll see where that that
takes us in a few
years a good chunk of those that were
lost in 2020 and outside of those years
have had comorbidities sure but with my
mechanic background I can tell you it's
cheaper at every level to put in the
preventative maintenance before an
endstage condition is found it's more
effective to treat these conditions
before they
progress as many of them can't be cured
past a certain
point and I'll make the argument that
it's just nicer to love one's neighbor
and care for them before they're sick
before they're transformed by these
illnesses for these reasons I consider
myself lucky to be able to support hr23
and I hope you do
too thank you for that uh again sharing
and personalizing
questions CA thank you so much for
coming over here thank you
okay we are looking at uh three more
cards here um also from Lebanon Alec
colado you can correct my pronunciation
Alec if you
would um so it's colado um and firstly
of course I'd like to thank uh you Mr
chairman and the rest of the
distinguished Representatives uh for the
opportunity to speak uh on this matter
that I think is really of of utmost
importance um when I first dawned my
white coat as a medical student at
Dartmouth I accepted for myself a
lifelong Duty uh to care for
people very often to care for people
that they're most
vulnerable um and I consider that an
enormous uh privilege and I consider
myself very fortunate to uh be in a
position to
uh take on that
responsibility but currently the Health
Care system in the United States is
standing in my
way the priority is
profit fortunately patients sometimes
receive the care that they
need I used to volunteer as a medical
interpreter at a free clinic which by
the
way I I think it's a little ridiculous
that free clinics exist in the United
States um but there I saw plenty of
low-income diabetic patients uh suffer
the long-term negative effects of being
unable to reliably afford
insulin I also met patients who hadn't
seen a doctor who had foregone necessary
screening uh in years because of
concerns regarding payment of course
these are not reare occurrences one in
five Americans had a prescription go
unfilled due to cost in this last year
2023 in the same year 8.7% of Americans
reported not seeing a doctor likewise
due to cost
concerns if we look at racial and ethnic
minorities separately those percentages
balloon into the mid
teens
don't
worry I'm going to take the best
possible care of
you I would like to utter those words to
my future patients without
hesitation but the only way that I'd be
able to offer the best care to my
patients all of my patients is if
they're covered sufficiently and
equitably as it
stands 88.3% of Americans are uninsured
nearly double if between the ages of 19
and 25 and triple if they're Hispanic
with other minority groups also covered
at lower rates than the
average at this
juncture we have the power to bring us
closer to a future where all Americans
can receive the medical care that they
both need and I believe
deserve and so for that reason I urge
you to vote in favor of
hr23 and although this issue can only be
corrected at the national scale My Hope
Is that New Hampshire's voice will be
used to create positive change not only
for the citizens of the State of New
Hampshire but also the citizens of the
United States at
large uh so thank you once again for
your time and for the platform and I'd
be happy to answer any
questions thank you Alec I'm G to ask
I'm gon to throw something out that I
maybe could have done or should have
done to some of your PR preceding um I
don't want to call them Witnesses
uh I'm sorry presenters uh Judge Lynn
who chairs Judiciary was watching it his
uh on YouTube I was watching some of his
he refers to the people as Witnesses but
he's a judge uh presenters yes it's um
typically when we have measures um we
have people from both sides or you know
Pro or con um and as I mentioned before
every single pink card that I have every
person here today speaking in favor of
the uh the
resolution um which is just fine um but
I I find myself uh very sympathetic to
everything I'm here of course and
appreciate people
personalizing but um I wish that like in
as is usually the case there is at least
one or two or or some folks who would uh
flag some of the what they see is
problems the resolution I'm not a health
care
expert um although I'm in Health Care
Systems as all of most of us are I've
spouse and a lot of people my family are
nurses and
whatever um but let me ask you this and
and I'll ask the same thing of the the
the last couple folks
um what what is a drawback with this
resolution we're hearing that it's good
and and there's no one here to to flag
any pieces of it that we that we should
uh also be thinking about so I'm asking
you to be kind of a devil's advocate if
you can you is
there what about this resolution should
we be concerned about or if
anything well as far as I understand it
um this resolution is effectively asking
uh to send the message that we need some
sort of a universal health care plan um
to Washington DC um and
so you know I'm not sure that it
um proposes any Direct Solutions
perhaps thank you for for trying that
one uh represent gagy sure go
ahead I don't have horns I promise okay
uh
[Music]
I didn't hear the first part of of your
your are you a medical doctor now I'm
I'm a medical student student okay now
when you graduate from Med medical
school you do your
internship if this becomes a Universal
Health Care uh situation now I know for
a fact my my daughter's an NP and not
all NPS make the same pay scale depends
where they work and what they do would
that affect fect your bottom line like a
doctor a chiropractor or a just a
GP the pay scale would be different who
would set that pay scale universally
throughout the
country I'm I'm sorry your question is
who would set the pay scale for
healthcare
providers yes if if this becomes sort of
like managed care if this should should
become like uh
it would be controlled
nationally okay now there's going to be
some cost savings going on somewhere
because you you you you want to give
everybody the same care that they
deserve I have no problem with that but
I know we all know for a fact that
medical professions as any other
profession not every Medical
Professional makes the same pay
scale so be you know for overhead so if
there was one price for a particular
procedure how would that work out if if
you're not making enough money to stay
in practice how do you stay in
practice
so I I think the best uh person to
answer that question would have been one
of the uh Physicians that are speaking
here today but as far as I um as far as
I am
concerned uh Health Care as it uh health
insurance as it is
today um often takes on the uh job of
determining whether certain procedures
are even medically necessary for
patients and the way that I see it the
only people that should be involved in
making that decision are healthc care
providers
um and
so I'm not sure if this is answering the
question or not but I think that at that
point payment uh would be determined by
the health care that is being delivered
to
patients thank you for allowing me to
put you on a spot represent
levit thank you chair Mett I'd like to
call up one of the presenters
please call back up thank you recall
thank you representative gagy
yes yes yeah the grayhair
guy only because I think carry on yes
oh cuz it's a terrific question and it's
an important
question yes in fact I was I was looking
for your card that's why I was uh so uh
please thank you I'm I'm I'm kend alart
so so you asked a really important
question that very few people including
doctors know the answer
to how do you determine how much a
physician gets paid for what they
do and it turns
out that there is a little known um
relative value scale committee or The
Ruck that is formed by the American
Medical Association
it consists of
27 leaders from different from 27
Specialties neurosurgery general surgery
vascular surgery and among those 27 are
three primary care Specialties
Pediatrics family medicine and uh
General Internal Medicine this
committee looks at well we think
spending an hour discussing one's
depression
and why you cannot take care of your
your diabetes
accordingly uh how much that is worth
versus half an hour in the
O uh repairing a hernia versus zapping a
non-cancerous potentially precancerous
lesion on an arm you get 80 bucks to do
this with a liquid nitrogen shot maybe
50 bucks to spend that half an hour or
an hour talking this is this committee
that committee
gives advice to centers for medical
services CMS which always takes their
recommendations one of the problems with
primary care is that there's only three
representatives of primary care on that
the a is a Lobby to to boost and support
Physicians salaries so guess where the
Bucks go um the other thing that is
important so so that's how salaries and
and reimbursement is currently set to an
extent
um the other thing by the way is private
insurers market so if I'm United healthc
care I want to say that I have more fine
cardiologists in the Portsmouth area
than Etna does or than Sigma does or
whatnot so guess what they will
boost um by about 300% in many instances
above what that recommended scale is to
attract and bring in more subsp
Specialists Primary Care gets boosted 5%
maybe it's 105% about what CMS
recommended for that reimbursement
that's part of the problem we have with
a nons
system um it's not looking at what you
actually need in the way of primary care
versus cardiologists versus
neurosurgeons it's based on other
factors so is
that helpful
uh and can I follow up thank you Mr
chairman and thank you Mr chairman for
allowing the doctor to come back
uh I've got a high school education so
I'm you know my my my son is a patent
attorney and my daughter's an NP so they
all have they did it way better than I
did I was a lumper which is why I've had
13 surgeries I was a black belt
instructor back in the last century and
that's what I knew
uh so would you say that this the AMC
with these
27 leaders the the American Medical
Association ama ama it's it's called The
Ruck the
relative AMA is good yeah am is good so
would you say that these 27
Specialists uh set parameters for what
will be charged for um hospital visits
or routine visits yes they make they
they give advice to centers for medical
services which which is what also sets
by the way Medicare reimbursement and
then private insurers use that as a
benchmark to booster or subtract um well
to boost uh reimbursement can I do one
more Mr chairman proceed thank you for
your
Indulgence um so these 27 lers if this
becomes if this should pass
Universal
glasses well Universal uh health
insurance program would this affect the
AMA with these 27 leaders would they
have to take instruction from the people
running this
thing no no I mean it's it's
interesting again we haven't talked
about the specifics of what a single
pair system would look like but it looks
like a lot like like Medicare except
improved and Universal not just for
folks who attain the age of
65 so Medicare currently is using which
needs to be reformed obviously there's
there's a crisis in Primary Care in the
United States so that this mechanism has
to be changed to some extent um but it's
a lobbying group so the but but it's
also entrenched as the mechanism that
sets prices I don't know what the
legislation would look like um to be
honest maybe that's the better answer
sir what ultimate legislation would look
like with providing Universal Insurance
for all Americans to
experience um would have mechanisms like
this in play but hopefully they'd be
reformed it' be nice to keep politics
out of it agree this is not political
this this is I agree with you this is a
part from politics thank you doctor for
uh stepping back up I mentioned earlier
that our clerk is uh one of the best oh
oh uh s simai uh you have a question for
this doctor uh represent yes sorry
representative Le sorry thank you uh CH
muet so let's be honest this has been
you know debated and legislated for
decades now I mean there's a lot of
money at stake with the insurance
companies and big Pharma um we go on by
saying it's that we don't want it to be
political it's very political it's
extremely political because there's a
lot um a lot of money in this um you
know we live in a capitalistic system
where people go to
school they go to
internship they become
doctors different type of
Physicians I don't think that part needs
to be
regulated problem I'm having here is
it's pretty simple
is if you want want to do something with
the Universal Health
Care we need to start small I understand
coming to the New Hampshire legislature
is the beginning of the process and I
respect that and and I thank you for
that but we're talking
about
lobbyists lawyers
organizations that will not
that do not want to upset the status quo
so what we're running into here is all
good Common Sense
legislation but we do run
into things
um um and and the question is Roadblocks
that is um something that we are not
going to be able to to
overcome your comments on
that um I think we all
recognize how much moneyed special
interests in Washington DC has affected
our
lives and what you are pointing out is
the difficulty in countering
marketing uh inducement of year in the
public about changes when there's a lot
of money in special interests
um the status quo is going to be
supported by that special interest
that's that's the nature of campaign
finance and the whole host of other
issues you are right this is Way Beyond
the legis the state house in New
Hampshire we're a small state we can't
do this on our own this is a
resolution saying two our Congressional
Representatives we recognize how people
are suffering
unnecessarily because of the um to to
basically provide profit uh for what's a
public good that should not have been
prophetie so the simple it's actually a
very simple process of making a
nonbinding resolution that people
recognize is the system is as terribly
broken and people are suffering as much
as they are for lack of a health
system by the way it's really cheap to
take care of kids you know you mentioned
starting
small kids don't cost a lot they need
immunizations they need well baby care
it's not pricey we talk about the
billions of dollars that are siphoned
off of Medicare and everything else
preventative care is not not expensive
uh covering folks who are currently
uninsured could actually even be done by
the various intermediary Health insurers
it's just they'd have to take a hit in
terms of their profit they'd have to be
responsible for that there's a lot of
ways to get from point A to point B I
guess is what I'm saying this doesn't
tell us how to form the legislation it's
just saying we recognize the issue needs
to be solved at a federal level if that
helps thank you for those comments thank
you doctor for your second appearance
and for uh also your point about this
being resolution as well taken sometimes
there's confusion as to uh HB versus an
HR this is a as you pointed out so well
this is a resolution resolutions can
matter uh they sometimes get more much
more attention than some bills do we
have two more cards uh Dr Fisher or
Fisher and also uh Laura Lynch I'll ask
Dr f is it Fisher or Fisher Dr
Fisher but uh and while he's approaching
the uh not the witness stand but the
presenter stand uh he's asked for up to
five minutes and then uh Laura our final
uh presenter uh three minutes um I also
uh I mentioned our clerk is one of the
best we also have one of the best uh
researchers uh suddenly appearing in my
hands as the pros and cons of
single-payer Health plants uh thank you
Christina for getting that to us that
was a question that I had had because no
one is speaking against this resolution
and and uh and that's okay uh but the
committee helps the committee to to get
some different perspectives so uh
welcome do you're from Dover so you're
not with Dartmouth Hitchcock correct no
I'm not okay yeah uh uh chairman mfet
Vice chair Rollins committee members uh
thank you for your time and allowing me
to speak to the committee uh I'm Dr
fiser I'm I'm retired primary care
physician and I represent myself but I'm
also a member of the granted State
Physicians for National Health plan and
I also chair of the uh New Hampshire
Healthcare Action Group it's a small but
growing group of individuals committed
to improving the access and quality of
Healthcare in New Hampshire and I also
live in representative Jessica L montin
legislative district in Dover um I had a
five minute presentation but I noticed
you had a lot of questions and I wrote a
few notes down uh and so I'm going to I
mean you've been sitting here for an
hour and 35 minutes listening to
testimony and I thought it might be
refreshing just to kind of sit back and
kind of answer a few questions some that
have already been asked uh and you might
have some fresh questions as well and I
thought that might be a better use of
our time um so uh chairman you had a a
question about uh immigrants and paying
for immigrants well first of all we're
paying for them now okay the difference
is these same people these immigrants
that are coming into the emergency room
by law we obliged to take care of we
can't just say sorry you're out on the
street uh and just die outside the
hospital someplace we we take care of
them but the problem is under the
present system the hospital gets to
charge an administrative fee and the
insurance companies that gets passed
along to the insurance companies the
insurance companies then have us pay for
it that's why insurance rates are one of
the reasons they're so high plus the
administrative fee that the insurance
companies put on us so by switching to a
universal healthcare we cut out a lot of
those middlemen and a lot of that
administrative fees as as Dr dolkart
pointed out the administrative fee for
the government run insurance plan of
Medicare is around 2 to 3% as opposed to
somewhere between 20 and 30% for Private
health insurances so the answer your
question is yeah taxpayers are still
paying for it we're stuck okay we can't
just let people die in the streets but
the but at least it's going to be
cheaper to pay for them under a
universal plan um uh uh representative
gagy you had a whole bunch of questions
about how this is going to be
administered and those are really good
questions and and besides the fact that
all the presenters had same thing in
common that we all were in favor of this
resolution we have something else in
common too and that is all the stories
that you've heard all the things that
you've heard from the doctors and from
the patients okay
there was a difference between who is it
that's going to manage your health care
is it going to be your doctor and and a
collaboration between the doctor and the
patient or is it going to be a private
health insurance these managed care
companies okay who's going to make the
decision somebody who's looking out for
Wall Street or someone whose sole
purpose is to look out for you now in
terms of what's the downside well there
can be a lot of downsides okay and as
you know Congress is kind of
dysfunctional at this time so yeah any
any small group of individuals who
have pretty secure congressional
districts can kind of mess things up and
they can change the formula any way they
want but you know we've got we're the
richest country in the world we spend
twice as much on healthare as any other
Nation does okay and we've got well of
the one of my statistics is we rank 58th
in terms of life expectancy 58th in in
the world okay it's kind of hard to
screw that up more than we've screwed it
up now all right can it be done well you
know I have a lot of faith in in
Washington that maybe they could do it
okay but I also have faith in both
Republicans and Democrats that that
people aren't totally stupid okay yeah
you get into office and you're you're
there to represent your your
constituents and some people people come
in with some weird agendas but most
people are honest we're all trying to
most of us are trying to do the right
thing for for the people that we
represent and and so I have faith that
eventually they'll come up with
something especially if we give them a
mandate that we want we want them to do
something we want to get things done so
what hr23 does basically is says
look you these private insurance
companies they spend Millions hundreds
of millions of dollars to Lobby Congress
people uh they they don't just Lobby
Cong they Lobby uh Chambers of Commerce
they try to get uh they try to get the
Chambers of Commerce to go against any
sort of uh deal that actually benefits
private businesses so it's hard to to
work up against those as as as
representative lit mentions but we have
a chance by sending it to on a national
basis and looking and taking the total
process I I I know I said I was going to
just answer questions but those those
were the questions that you asked I
wanted to address some of those thank
you for that Dr uh R
gagy thank you thank you Doctor
uh my big concern of all of
this is not I don't want to care for
people to have have them cared for it's
government mandates that would tell me
if I'm if I have when I have children
that this is what you have to do with
your children you have to bring them in
to do this you have to bring them in to
do that government mandates have always
bothered me would you you know I was say
yeah there was uh would you believe uh
we are supposed to ask questions and
that technically was would you would you
believe what he just said Doctor uh I
yeah I I understand about government
mandates uh and and I have the same sort
of concerns about government mandates as
well I I definitely share that with you
uh fortunately with the examples that I
have and I've also worked for the VA
system okay um when it comes to Health
Care the government mandates have been
more about the financial aspects and not
about the personal aspects uh there are
some concerns about you know uh of what
we're going to cover what for Co what
what counts as costs and so on but you
know those are all upfront uh when it
comes to um especially about Medicare uh
Doc and I've worked with a lot of
Medicare patients you know what you're
dealing with you know what they're going
to approve and what they're not going to
approve so the rate of of denials for
government run uh health insurance
Medicare is next to zero the rate of
denials for private healthare is close
to 30% so in terms of mandates who's
really giving you the
mandates it's it's really the private
companies that are doing the mandates
not the government thank you for that
doctor
uh other questions yes representative
levit thank you chair
maret so as we
know how hr23 reads is is calling upon
the New Hampshire Congressional
Delegation to support a national
universal health insurance program we
support you then what doctor I beg you
we decide this is a good resolution
we're bypassing support then what well
you know if if you pass this on and if
you approve of it then basically what
happens is our Congressional
Delegation takes a stand and there's
some there's some real advantages to
that especially coming from New
Hampshire that actually it was one of
the things I actually wrote down before
I I came up here uh and let me see if I
can find it here uh oh yeah look I I've
only lived in New Hampshire for 35 years
um but you know New Hampshire is known
for pragmatism okay yeah we get
political okay but we're more pragmatic
than anything else and we also none of
us like wasteful spending we have to be
frugal with our bucks and we're really
good at that as a state so coming this
resolution being sent to Washington from
our Congressional Delegation tells the
rest of the nation look we're tired of
spending wasting government money and
wasting private money on things that
aren't doing anything for us you know
when you look when you when you look at
the outcomes from Private health
insurance they're horrible I mean
they're great for for making money for
people but in terms of actual health
care it's terrible and so we want our
health care System to take care of
Health Care and it's a very practical
it's a very pragmatic thing and that's
what we're known for that's what we're
good at and so let's tell the rest of
the nation that's what we want thank you
thank you doctor and we did touch on
that earlier in terms of the value of a
resolution versus a bill I have two more
any other quick questions for the Dr
while he's on the presenters
area seeing none uh thank you for your
extra time and and for your flexible
format uh I mentioned we had one more
card I actually have two represent
Horgan has also asked for one minute uh
but uh Laura Lynch has been is she still
here she been waiting patiently Laura
welcome uh Laura to ask for three
minutes Laura is here from
Temple Temple New
Hampshire okay
sure hi my name is Laura Lynch from
Temple New Hampshire thank you for
letting me
speak um a lot of people have been
talking um about you know how to get
universal healthcare I'm going to tell
you my story
um my husband fell and broke his hip his
leg in August of
2022 he was back and forth in the
nursing home and the hospital for four
weeks he was finally released within a
week after he got a stomach ache and we
rushed him to the hospital to find out
that he had appendicitis now my husband
had a number of underlining conditions
on top of what the
appendicitis um we waited in the waiting
room for 7 hours 7 hours to see a doctor
in an emergency room because they sent
us to the emergency room the only ones
that are going first in emergency rooms
is if you call it um an ambulance and
the cost of an ambulance right now is
$1,250 to take you 30 minutes to a
hospital and then they want a $300
co-pay on top of it
so needless to say um my husband I was I
was told that night to go home because
of my husband's underlying conditions
they were going to keep in the hospital
for several days or for a few days
anyways um I was awoken at 5:30 that
morning by a nurse asking me what his
meds were and all kinds of stuff and
they told me how the surgery went and
everything and as far as I knew they
were keeping him I got woken up at 9:30
by my husband to tell me that they were
discharging him eight hours after the
surgery was over he was still under
anesthesia and he he was told to sign
paperwork while I was at home I I I
wasn't there to protect him because
there's a lot of people who really need
to protect protection from hospitals
insurance
companies my husband came home and
within a week he was rushed to CMC with
an
infection this had section eventually
killed my husband after 2 months he was
63 years
old
um I had to fight he
um was in the hospital for 10 days going
back and forth with the insurance
company to find out that um he had a
bleed in his heart and they were looking
for it everywhere else and he ended up
having open heart surgery and having his
um one of his his
um pipes replaced I forget what it is
exactly I'm sorry and um but the
infection continued because no one can
get it so um he finally was able to get
discharged it was a Sunday they told me
that we're going to discharge him but we
haven't found a place for him and I
wanted him to be in a place that had a
Hos that was in a hospital and I was
asking them to to send him to St
Joseph's Hospital for the rehab because
they had a he had a pick in him and they
would still had to give him medications
and stuff like that so I went home that
day thinking that my husband was finally
going to
rehab um I called him the next morning
he was
fine um I so I said to him I'm staying
home it been two months of driving from
Temple to to Manchester twice what back
and forth twice a day um so I came back
on
Tuesday and my husband had no idea who I
was and I got a message from and I was
screaming at what the heck
happened um what's going on nobody knew
um found out but that one of the nurses
there said that they had given him a
medication that was already already ad
he had an adverse reaction to and they
just thought maybe they tried it again
so my husband ended up um back in the
ICU this was the day before
Thanksgiving so Thanksgiving morning
they rushed him into the ICU for the
fourth time four times he was rushed
into the
ICU when I got there the doctors was
saying to me what the hell happened and
I said to them I have no idea what
happened we left him he was fine he was
ready to go to
rehab and he um ended up in the
ICU it was the weekend after
Thanksgiving his birthday was on
November 26th and I was so excited I
went out to get a cake and to bring it
back and I found out that he wasn't
breathing correctly and they had to put
him on B they had him on BiPAP for a
while but his breathing was getting
worse and worse and his his
body was shutting down so that next
morning they said to me um he's coming
in here um we his his body is shutting
down but we think if we go and have do
surgery that he has a 50% chance of
surviving well they were waiting for a
vascular surgeon to come in that day um
it was on November
27th and um she came in she checked him
out she came back in and she looked at
me through the door and she just went
like
this my husband would have had to have
his leg cut off and his arm cut off and
he had a 10% chance of surviving surgery
so having to make a decision to shut the
machines off for your husband is the
worst thing you ever had to do but
having to hear doctors and nurses at the
hospital tell me that they had their
hands tied in their feet tied because
they couldn't do anything unless they
got the okay from an insurance
company I have Medicare Advantage I
don't want Medicare Advantage anymore I
want regular Medicare and they will not
allow us to get off a Medicare
Advantage our 3% increase this year for
our social security I didn't get it
because my dental went from $60 to $90 a
month so there goes my 3% of my
race it's getting ridiculous I started
with Medicare at $84 it's now
$174 a month so out of my measley social
security check they're taking out almost
$300 a month and this is what I'm trying
to survive on we need Universal Medicare
we need universal
healthcare people like I cannot afford
it I have a subscription right now for
PT and I can't go because it's
$45 an appointment and if you're doing
three appointments a week it's over $120
out of my $1,800 a month Social Security
check Lord thank you for personalizing
and for sharing that when folks are able
to do that it it helps us to to on a
personal level to see how circumstances
affect people I think it's pretty clear
why you mark down that you support the
uh would you take a question if there if
there is any I would love to answer any
questions
um not seeing any uh thank you again for
coming here from Temple and sharing
that we have one representative Horan
ask for one minute represent
Horgan so as probably everybody knows
I'm president Timothy Horgan from from
uh straford County District 10 the town
of Durham and um I'm current I've been
on a um single-payer government plan for
two years uh Medicare which uh you heard
about before uh and I have the regular
traditional Medicare plus a supplement
with by a private insurance company so
that that works uh that works well I
don't consider that a bur of of
government mandate one thing about
before that for several years I had an
Affordable Care Act policy sometimes
called Obamacare which is a positive
dictate for some people and negative for
others and that also was certainly
better than anything that was available
to me through like the employer provided
and certainly forget about the indidual
insurance Market is pretty much uh
pretty much worthless for some point me
I was bit aged but still in good health
so I think um certainly the Medicare
system is not perfect but as others have
pointed it is uh very predictable and of
course get the supplement plans there's
also the advantage plan which is sort of
a free market solution which uh
it didn't work well for the previous uh
witness
I I I I just evaluate them they seem
like a bad idea even though they are a
free market solution they weren't good
but um so I think I mean so I think we
should send the delegation this letter
obviously the four people who the
members of our delegation all pretty
much uh on that side of the issue um but
still it's it's a it's useful to rein
reinforce it and we don't know if those
four members of the Congressional
Delegation will be there forever so I
think um and then well rent gagne's out
here but he's complaining about
government mandates I think the
insurance companies are also a level of
government they're just not a level of
government that is not accountable to
anybody but their own uh sh stockholders
I think probably we should use something
we should have a federal program that's
along the line of Medicare and then um
president L montin handed out that
handed out that document you've all seen
they also mentioned there's Tri care was
the military ones so I think um you know
it's not just veterans who have health
issues it's not even just old people I
know um there's many young people who
have serious medical issues um
so so I would just say vote Yes in this
resolution and we go ahead and send go
and go ahead and send the the letter on
nice probably some nice formal
stationary to the delegation and it's
not going to make a huge difference but
it'll make a small positive difference
so um I would urge you to vote Yes I
suppose that quite possibly may be voted
yes because I'm going to be for here for
the executive session so thank you thank
you representative your card did not say
what you were for but obviously you you
were for this clearly thank you
permission to check that
off seeing no questions thank you again
represent forgan at this time I am going
to uh that was our last measure um we're
now at it's a little after 11:30 we're
into the executive uh exe part what I
need to do what I want to do what I will
do at this time uh um and don't panic we
are going to caucus uh the the first
exact measure we will take up will be
hr31 now that is the measure that we did
open in recess uh there were no pink
cards um as the chair uh before we
recess I would like to ask the uh there
was one prime sponsor for hr31 which
again we will exact first I'd like uh to
ask represent Sweeney who is here uh if
this is not a hearing but it's
informational at my discretion if you
would uh briefly just before we go to
exec uh give us a quick U explanation of
hr31 if you would absolutely thank you
very much Mr chairman and the members of
the state federal Relations Committee
our representative Joe Sween from
Rockingham 25 um so I do have an
amendment in from OS on this house
resolution I'm not sure if they've been
able to get it over to you it's a simple
Amendment I'm passing around a handout
of the actual bill uh we're trying to
get Congress to to support uh through
this resolution the title that I had
submitted to OS was the dignity through
Prosperity act but the new title of the
legislation is the defi uh the patent
extend terminate the extended patent act
um which is being passed around now so
it's a simple Amendment it just replaces
the word the name of the legislation uh
from what's in the house resolution
currently to what is now in front of you
uh as the as the title of the bill um so
excuse me so as you know we're uh going
into exec session and we will do you
have a member of the committee to uh
introduce this when we when we come back
to exec S I don't I don't currently know
I I don't have the copy of the amendment
on me yet okay so sorry I do uh I
believe this is it but uh go ahead carry
on we we just need somebody to introduce
and uh second the amendment but sure
please continue to describe I I want to
say so this bill this resolution I filed
is on behalf of my constituent Earl Cobb
who's over here uh in his wheelchair um
he's a patent owner and and the the goal
of the legislation is to urge Congress
to to provide more security more
flexibility uh to disabled patent owners
um that are that hold patents within the
country um and it's just suggest it's
just proposing to Congress and asking
them to support the legislation that he
is he has drafted and he's pushing for
um that's really the sum of it the the
one-page resolution that we have not
doesn't touch Medicaid Medicare any any
of the Hot Topic issues it's just in
support of proposing this legislation to
Congress okay representative Sweeney um
I'm going to ask that you get with
representative Manion because he is uh a
a go-to guy with with for amendments
perfect um so we want to make sure that
the wording you want us to take up
during our exec session which we're
getting into um is properly uh
understood and introduced so um we are
going to recess and come back to exec
session um so if you can get with reps
some Manion on that so that we make sure
we have the amendment now this what I'm
looking at here is not an approved
Amendment uh no it is not so and that
and that is simply that is a copy of the
act that we want to go for congress it's
the title of it is the only thing that's
changing in this resolution so the
resolution is staying the same except
the title through Prosperity Act is
changing to the extended patent term act
that's on that bill that's on that paper
okay now we can't we we can't um we
need a formal amendment I no an OS is is
getting it drafted I just don't have the
copy of it yet from all us okay that
happens all the time so I understand
that I'm going to leave it up to you
though U to get with representative
Manion and if we get the amendment we
can take it up if we don't then then we
can't take it up
absolutely
um uh yes representative uh Mr chairman
will the amendment replace this whole
bill uh what what is I believe you your
intent uh explain would you the intent
of the amendment is to change every
instance of the phrase dignity through
Prosperity act to the extended patent
term act which is the the paper that is
in front of you that's just it's simply
replacing the name of the act as the the
name has changed since I filed the
resolution everything else in the house
resolution will stay the same except for
the instances in which dignity through
Prosperity act appears it'll be replaced
with extended patent term
act okay well thanks for explaining that
and and you understand how things work
here we we need to have uh the amendment
if we don't have the amendment you know
I'll we'll uh exact uh or we we'll make
a decision on on a but it sounds like
this is in the works uh we're always
hearing OS is working on it so we're
going to break and uh we will uh we will
see what they come back with M has a
question yeah represent Mass
sh explain the bill to us because I'm
not clear nor is representative lungren
and exactly what it's asking yes thank
you representative uh again we open this
and recess it through no pink I I read
it and reread it and I've said to my
colleagues I didn't really understand it
that well it's and now there's an
amendment that that we're going going to
take up uh if we get it uh so be again
before we break
if not all of
us understand what we're about to exact
as well as we'd like to so can you take
another couple minutes in respond to
represent Melo and and I did file this
on behalf of a constituent who's here
and can take questions but I know we're
not in a public hearing uh this
bill we are in a public hearing so I do
have a public hearing now on the
bill well this is uh not scheduled as a
public hearing this is that's this
problem this is a ex we've finished our
public hearing we've gone to exec
session uh
and the amendment that I heard was
forthcoming I I just we just need to get
a handle on that uh well Mr chairman the
without due respect to the chair and I'm
this just for every's
edification if uh representative Manion
wants to bring that amendment in into
the committee when we take it up in
executive session he can explain what
the amendment does right by having the
sponsor of the bill now testify you
reopened the hearing correct and that's
what we it hasn't been posted that
exactly right that's why we are talking
about this in the context of an exact
session so repres shirtliff is right and
he's he's saying what I have said
earlier uh we this is not a hearing
we'll take the amendment up if the if if
the amendment is forthcoming is
representative Sher have represent
Manion can speak to it so I'm going to
leave it to you and the possible
introducer and he'll need a second so
that's where we stand and we will come
back to that
um
so that's where we stand thank you okay
uh so
we are in exact session I'm going as
I've said a couple times we're going to
uh Don't Panic we're going to uh recess
we will have uh we will
have caucuses so it's
11:55
uh TW Let's uh let's come back here at
12:45 uh Madam ranking ranking member
that gives you 50 minutes for lunch in
caucus
if you need to grab lunch so you have 50
minutes so I'll leave that to your
caucus to manage that 50 minutes on the
on the red team uh let's let's meet
right now uh in the office and um we
will reconvene for the rest of the
executive session at
12:45
for
hey folks one minute one
minute
okay as soon as the ranking member is is
seated take your time represent
masso especially because you're giving
out uh helpful uh helpful items yes I
did I got my helpful item all right at
this time uh we will commence our
executive session uh we have uh me see
seven measures that we will exec today
and that'll finish our work uh we have a
Senate bill on Monday and then uh we'll
see if we get anything for
crossover um or not
so before I thank anybody body for all
their great work let's see how this see
how this goes today uh first one is the
is kind of the big one I've received
like seems like hundreds of messages
maybe some of you have as well on um HP
1156 the U measure that has to do with
sovereignty the CDC The Who and I'm
there's an amendment percolating um reps
of Manion uh I I think it was just
passed out would you yeah I so while you
were all gone I did put the amendment
there so I it's Amendment uh
82h so you're making a mo a motion to
amend
1156 with uh Amendment 0582 H yes do we
have a
second represent L second you ready to
to rock and roll
here when you're ready any want to get
ahead of you Mr chairman representative
Yeah question for the sponsor of the
amendment on the
amendment just just waiting for make
sure the clerk's ready oh I know
okay may I inquire uh yes oh thank you
Mr chairman um the first line of the
bill says the World Health Organization
shall have no jurisdiction in New
Hampshire do they currently have
jurisdiction in New
Hampshire uh currently no uh the idea
here is in case we enter into any kind
of treaties or something in the future
that may give them Supremacy over the
state okay thank you thank you Mr
chairman so this is preemptive language
kind of to representative shortless
Point preemptive
yes
okay
uh R man what uh what else would you
like to say with regard to your
Amendment so this the amendment is
pretty much the same bill that we've
already seen except it removes all the
uh references to the central Centers for
Disease Control and specifically focuses
on the World Health Organization uh the
idea here is that uh trying to limit the
CDC there are arguments especially some
of the emails we've seen from nurses and
such saying that there could be
potential problems with the even uh you
know rudimentary things that we use
every day that cite the CDC it wouldn't
be great but the World Health
Organization is like a a extra National
Organization represent LE anything to
your second I'll concur with that I
agree with representative
man okay I have just a quick comment on
the amendment um the original measure
the resolution uh basically specifically
mentioned the CDC and the wh and
concerns about overreach by them
obviously related to the uh Co
pandemic um the
amendment takes out the CDC part and
leaves in the
wh uh Mr chairman I think it's as you
were
it's I think um the amendment takes out
the World Health Organization and no no
no it removes the CDC and relieves world
where the idea is that we're trying to
uh keep the World Health Organization
out of influencing the state politics
things along those nature so like we we
left the CDC we we removed it from the
bill so that it no longer affects them
it only affects World Health
Organization I sit corrected so I
understand the animist the concerns we
we heard a lot a lot a lot of testimony
about uh perceived real or imagined uh
overreach by the CDC during the uh
pandemic and subsequent to the Bas when
the pandemic ended or or petered out
however you want to put it uh in
retrospect a lot of the CDC uh policies
recommendations mandates in some cases
uh were found to be faulty at least in
the minds of uh many people healthc Care
Professionals and or not so
understandably the the folks who thought
that the CDC overreached uh that was
part of the reason for the resolution
the the problem in terms of sovereignty
um for me is the CDC is part of our
Sovereign government uh it's it's
American it's part of our government the
wh uh is not the who as we heard uh
someone testified there was it was a
communist who was the head of it I you
know that was some of the testimony that
we heard on the
who so I support the amendment I
understand the problems with the CDC but
I support the amendment because the who
clearly clearly
uh does does not and in my opinion
should not have sovereignty the who
should not be dictating uh medical
policy to uh States or organizations in
the United States so I support the
amendment um other other
thoughts oh and by the way I want to
welcome our subs uh we have we have six
uh representative spear for
representative Boris
welcome uh representative Lane is back
uh for representative O'Neal welcome
back representative Horgan I've seen him
before he's here for uh representative
toll representative
lel's uh thank you for being here for
representative finny representative dun
good to see you here for representative
Harley and representative Bogard is here
for representative Pani
welcome okay so back to uh 11:56 I just
uh waigh in on other yes uh
representative spear thank you
uh my understanding is and of course I'm
not an expert but I've been around the
block on this a little bit states are
not allowed to enter into any kind of
treaty with a foreign government nor are
they allowed to cancel a treaty that the
federal government makes with a foreign
government so the basis for claiming
that we can't that we can Outlaw a
treaty that may have been set up that
has a an hwo component to it I'm not
sure you can do
that and this is an HB this is not a
resolution it is a house bill so that
would be
statutory that that is a fair
observation other
thoughts rent shortliffe
thank you Mr chairman uh with all due
respect to the bill sponsor the World
Health organiz oration was created in
1946 or 48 and that past 76 years there
never been a problem and I think this is
kind of a little bit of overreach if
there's an issue then address it but
there hasn't been and I don't
contemplate one thank you Mr
chairman there was a lot of uh again
this is exact session there was a great
deal of testimony um from people the uh
the doctor who spoke at Great l about
the who
uh seemed to cite some specific concerns
that that she had with the who in
particular that that did resonate with
with
me any uh other other thoughts
representive Lloyd um I'm just uh thank
you Mr chairman um I'm just thinking
back to some of the testimony that she
actually gave and in one of those uh one
of those lines it did claim that there
was still sovereignty for our government
um within that treaty that would be
going through I thought that's one of
the lines that we had picked out when we
were going through
everything that's
correct uh someone else had a hand
up thank you I'm to a guest here so I
take too long but I'm concerned although
I think the bill stops doesn't go quite
far enough for this problem to crop up
but that may be still part of the intent
of it which is this would prevent um
public this would prent certain uh
public entities in the state from you
know collaborating or contributing to
research in which the who is required of
which there is always a lot especially
during during the pandemic which uh
which I think is still going on but
that's just my opinion um certainly
specifically for example the uh HHS also
the secretary the vital records unit
which is under the Secretary of State's
office um lacks a lot of data and then
also quazi public entities would
certainly include the uh member the
member institutions of the University
system in both UNH and Plymouth state in
particular had extensive research uh
programs and other programs connected
with the pandemic so I think uh I mean I
don't think this would actually prevent
them
from from doing doing that sort of work
but I still think I would not want to
take the chance of somehow we forbidden
them from you know
collaborating in other health issues
that crop up in the future so
thanks thank you representative uh
representative
levit I feel this is a preemptive bill I
mean our states were Sovereign um I
don't think that
um you know what the who um fears or how
about um a dictates would um be
um divulged into or mandated by the
state of New Hampshire so I just think
it's a pre preemptive Bill and I'm going
I'm all in on that
one other
comments we have a motion on the floor
to
amend and before we call the role on the
amendment I do want to point out as I
pointed out at the last exec session
oftentimes amendments
uh every amendment is intended to
approve the measure whether you agree
with or not most cases uh a good case is
made for the amendment the the case made
here was in terms of sovereignty there's
a stronger case to be made for focusing
on the who in terms of sovereignty
issues as opposed to the
CDC so taking the CDC out uh as the
amendment does uh should should address
I think some of the concerns that raised
so whether or not the ultimate you can
ultimately support otpa if it is amended
uh I hope I hope that they can be some
support for this amendment moving
forward last call for comments before we
run the role on the
amendment seeing No Hands Madame clerk
uh the motion is on the amendment to HB
1156 the amendment is
058 2
H okay representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative was Phyllis here no no
who's replacing Phyllis nobody no one
nobody okay a representative levit yes
representative Dunn yes representative
gagy yes representative bogert yes
representative LEL yes representative
Manion yes represent shirtliff no
representative Mass Milla no
representative spear no oh sorry
no representative
G yes representative Horgan no
representative Judy no madame
representative Lloyd no representative
Lane no representative Sebert no
representative Figo oh he's not here
either is
he no okay
all right and the
chair chair votes yes to the
amendment six seven eight nine 10 2
eight
eight is that right is one two three
four five six seven eight yep 10 eight
yep let me just
check no we're missing Sean and Phil
missing to so it should it should add up
to 18 y so have 18 it does add up to Y
and you
voted so the amendment passes uh 10 to8
so the next issue the next item is uh
the we need a motion on otpa I motion
otpa oh do we have a second yes I'll
second that chair okay Madam clerk once
again again uh represent Manion motions
otpa on
1156 and represent levit second
set um we've already had quite a lot of
discussion on the amendment as a whole
but uh R man would you like to speak to
your a lot of the stuff that we already
covered I thought there was it covered
very well one of the mentioning of
treaties like uh if we move into a
situation where the United States starts
entering into these treaties that
adversely affect the the population of
the United States we should we should as
a state do everything in our power to
restrict that not only Federal overreach
but it's International overreach into
the very you know day-to-day lives of us
and we should be pushing back against
that and you know if we have to call on
Article Five to uh revoke our uh treaty
binding to the state so be it but I
think this is a good start
here thank you representative I I share
your sentiments uh representative Lev to
your
second I concur I mean we you know again
this is preemptive but I think it works
for what we need during our present
State other thoughts re CRA your red
lights on oh yeah oh I'm sorry I kind of
left it on yeah I do have a thought it
was brought up during the hearing about
enforcement of this
legislation and we were told that it
would be the people and um yeah I'm not
going to vote for this cuz I believe
that's a dangerous precedent to or I
mean it's yeah it's a dangerous
precedent to set yeah being a house bill
so thank
you thank you representative uh
representative Lloyd I just feel like
rejecting the guidance of the who in New
Hampshire really undermines Public
Health efforts and promotes in
misinformation during a potentially
troubling time and confusing time um if
we look back at the covid uh pandemic
like hindsight is 2020 you know we're
finding out things that yeah you know I
may regret disinfecting all of my
groceries that were brought into the
house but I mean we science changes as
things go on and this jeopardizes the
safety and well-being of residents and
collaboration with um reputable health
organizations is essential for
effectively addressing Health crises and
Protec in the population from infectious
diseases I mean it's just it it we need
that guidance sometimes especially when
people are really nervous and really
upset I'm sure that when a woman walked
into my doctor's appointment wearing
trash bags you know um she probably
regrets that decision now but hindsight
is 2020 and you know everybody was
nervous and everybody was
scared thank you represent of I don't I
don't as I read this uh amended measure
I don't see it as rejecting The Who per
se I I think it's a sovereignty issue I
I see it as a statement that the who
does not have uh you know the power to
mandate policies in this country um I I
agree that there there is some Services
some information they can provide it it
for us to take at our discretion so I
don't see it as us rejecting the who I
do see it as an affirmation of our
sovereignty um rep Manan does that is
that square with your yeah and the one
thing I would say is like so we have uh
like first order uh when the infection
spreads everybody's going to get sick
and all that but then a lot of these
countries were especially coming from
China they had these uh as I think it
was representative um beler was talking
about how they uh amped up the fear to
get us to change our policies and the
World Health Organization went along
with like these Chinese demonstrated
policies that were very damaging to like
families livelihoods and second order
effects where people were just too
scared to go to the doctor because they
were afraid they were going to drop dead
in the street so there there's going to
be people now as we're seeing as the
years go on that are going to die of
preventable diseases that they didn't go
get treated because they were terrified
out of their minds that they were going
to drop dead in the streets but
represent Manion to representative
Lloyd's point do do you see this as a
rejection of the wh wh per se I wouldn't
say no I wouldn't say it's a rejection
of the who the individual people people
like whoever wants to go and listen
their guidance that you know that
information is going to be published on
the internet every individual's uh
ability to make their own choice is not
restricted here it just restricts
government from uh and listening to the
World Health World Health World health
organizations recommendations and
implementing uh MK mandates vaccine
mandates whatever it may be following
their guidance which can't be
trusted Lloyd did you have a a finger up
um yeah just to point out again that
this is a bill and not a resolution and
that's my that's one of my biggest
concerns with all of this here um is
that there are legally binding uh things
that happen with this
so yes there is that distinction which
we pointed out representative uh cot as
we've kind of established today it seems
this would affect the VA then I'm saying
like my husband went to the VA to get
his covid
shot um instead of doing the National
Guard thing he was able to go to the VA
he always puts things off anyway doesn't
work but he went to the VA and got it
done like immediately and it was very
effect of so would he not be able to do
that then that's that's a government
entity well this says specifically for
the New Hampshire and our the state and
its political subdivision so like the
the VA would be a federal uh healthc
care facility that we can't really do
much about okay represent
spear thank you uh not having heard the
hearing and I so I would appreciate a
clarification it doesn't quite read like
a bill and in a bill if you mandate
something then you're supposed to see a
penalty if you don't do that and so I
don't see any enforcement capability in
this
bill and so therefore it really doesn't
Define itself as a as a legal bill
format so do you have any comment about
that yeah thank you repres that's a fair
observation uh the the language is what
it is uh that question has come up
before we did look at the language we
did amend it but the the extent of the
amending process that we did or that was
done uh focused on uh The Who as opposed
to the CDC so the enforcement mechanism
issue still is is uh is obviously an
issue for some folks like you just
pointed out so what do we do about that
I mean can you pass something that isn't
really a bill exactly we have a uh a
motion on the floor and it's been
amended once so at this point in the
process uh we have to uh go yay or nay
on on the motion which is uh
otpa anything else representative uh
Lane thank you Mr chair I just wanted to
Echo some of the other concerns because
the last P the last sentence is is
troubles me in the sense it says no
shall not be used there's no option and
I thought I heard several people
indicate well you can the state has the
option and the word shell leaves no
option so we the the state cannot use
any of the World Health Organization
data information to justify any mask
vaccine or medical testing requirements
I mean they're drawing data from all
over the world and and science does
change and I guess I and it says and
shall have no force or effect in New
Hampshire and I think it was
representative Oregon who indicated that
you know Public Health probably over
over in new H the University of New
Hampshire probably use that data and use
it to support a lot of things that they
come up with so are we restricting them
because reading this I would say we're
telling them they cannot use that
because it says shell
I take that as a bit of a rhetorical
question uh it it at this at
this someone had a a hand uh
representative lren yeah my my point on
that is if you read it is World Health
Organization will mandate that we have
to wear a mask vaccine or medical tests
um that's why I think I'm definitely
against said I don't want World Health
Organization telling me what I should do
um and follow the CDC um uh guidelines
thank you and you say that is a medical
professional you're you're in the
business right yes sir uh Reon
bogert turn
you thank you Mr chairman uh and
following up on that uh line8 nine and
10 it says further more any requirements
mandates and instructions by this
organization shall not be used but it
does not say that we cannot use the test
data in order to further the research
that is done here by
rcdc it just states that if the uh
wh the World Health Organization says
you will get your shots and that's the
end of the subject we don't have to
follow it it says we're going to mandate
y'all to do it we don't have to follow
it it doesn't say we cannot take their
research and validate it with our
research being done at UNH and stuff
there's nothing in here saying you can't
take the data it just says you do not
take the Mandate from them that you do
what we tell you to do that's all it's
stated
thank you represent B yes to
representative Lane Lane's Point uh I
read this is simply saying that
W mandates um shall not be used in the
state to justify in other words if
you're a a school or a business or any
entity and you want to put in a mask
mandate that I think is a local decision
but you can't according to this you
can't use the Who as a sole
justification a wh mandate is a sole
justification for a uh mask
mandate okay uh representive Horgan yes
we mentioned um we mentioned China I
think China has three times the
population of the US so they're even
even though we're a very large country
they're even bigger and I'm just from
what I I tried to keep up I was going
there as best I could which not very
well they I think whatever they did was
primarily directed at what was going on
in China trying to uh stop the pandemic
in China so I don't think they were
necessarily trying to scare us as far as
I know they the Chinese people pretty
much Chinese government pretty much
ignores us as long as we you know send
as long as we like send them their
manufacturing plants money I don't think
they well that's not relevant to the no
exactly fair enough yes but something is
more relevant the lot the mass we got
remember uh Dean Cayman flying the
Manchester airport with all those ppes
um those were all made in China and then
a lot of the M devices are in fact made
in China because they're a big part of a
global economy and um and of course
those masks are not 100% effective I bit
that as for the vaccines okay again the
the efficacy of The Masks is not the
issue the issue is whether we want to
allow or we want to uh have wh mandates
uh subject to use to employ and enforce
policies here yeah the V and the VAC
vacines they've been blamed for every
adverse Health thing that's happened to
anybody in the United States or the
world since the vaccines were started
circulating I guess it was two years ago
but those events happened during the
pandemic and before and of course
something we did have during the
pandemic was a billion extra deaths just
in the US from respiratory disease which
is uh actually is much bigger than
anything that's been tied rightly or
wrongly to the basks or the vaccines but
um so okay but anyway thank thank you
for that reprentative
other other uh representative Lloyd I'm
just trying to recall everything during
Co because um I mean for me it was very
different than a lot of you I was in and
out of the hospital constantly I had
five surgeries throughout 20120 and um
because you all masked because you all
took precautions I was able to go into
surgeries and not have to worry about
whether or not I contracted covid so um
there are positive effects for things
but I'm kind of curious back during
those days it wasn't just The Who that
we were using for mandates it was a
combination of um of people and of
organizations that we were using in
order to create mandates so it's not
like doing this is not in my opinion
going to help anything or further
anything it it may potentially harm
things by taking information away from
the
public thank you
representative uh representative b u you
something
new yes
and our society here in America depends
on our
CDC to give us directions and stuff so
when the mass mandate came down it
wasn't as the World Health Organization
was pushing their their agenda the CDC
was by an act of the presidents have
given us that direction we should wear
the mask and so the whole country as a
whole following CDC not the World Health
Organization wore masks then the Advent
of the shots came into play and then
that's where things started falling
apart because the research
wasn't being forthright and does and so
now we having to follow something from
the CDC mandate based on the World
Health Organization mandate that says
you're going to go do this when now it
divided the society because there wasn't
no data and and the FDC had did not uh
qualify this drug that we were told to
go take as a vaccine so
this place here does not take any of
that away it's the point I'm trying to
say as long as our CDC stays
intact then it gives direction for the
American people to do so it doesn't
undercut any medical situation it
doesn't undercut any
research because research is not a
mandate that you have to do something it
is just there so that you have the
ability to incorporate that data into
all the different data sets that are
available this bill does not take that
away it just says if the World Health
Organization dictates you to do
something we don't have to follow it
thank you thank you representative and
again to your point the CDC has been the
amendment removed the CDC from the
equation here representative shortle
believe me Mr chairman I don't want to
prolong this I'm getting older by the
minute but uh uh I have now have a
question that the other members of this
committee made me think about what hav't
forbid if we have another pandemic and
the state
enologist recommends to the governor
mandatory mass and a reporter says to
the state
enologist what did you base this idea of
Mass on and he or she says on the
information provided by the wh and CDC
because he said those three awful words
wh does that
nullify the ability to wear masks uh
that's a good question and that's why I
asked it and my take on that is that the
entm I'm saying not saying it right
entomologist studies something else but
the uh the Benjamin the Dr Chan the Dr
Chan type person uh if this happens
again should not mention the who because
if he wants to justify a mask mandate he
would need to justify some other
entity anything else
Mr chairman Mr yeses gag oh thank you
you're gonna you're going to do what I'm
suggesting that we beat this horse to
death now I think we all know how we're
going to vote and what we're going to
vote so I would move the vote sir y uh
okay represent G moves the vote I saw no
hands at any rate the the question is on
the OTP motion
for uh otpa for HB 1156 when you're
ready Madam chair um the motion is otpa
representative Rollins yes
representative lungren yes
representative levit I representative
dun yes representative gagy yes
representative bogert yes representative
lels yes representative Manion yes
Representative shirtliff no
representative Mass Miller noes
representative spear no representative
KY no representative Horgan no
representative Judy no Madam
representative Lloyd no representative
Lane no representative Sebert no no
okay and the
chair yes to
otpa
okay
99 do we need
tion no well you have you can make that
motion well I'm
sorry
so the motion fails uh with a N9 to9
vote
uh Mr
chair it would when we exhaust the uh
amendments or not the Amendments but the
uh alter alternative motions it would go
to the floor 9 to9 uh depending upon
subsequent motions I see one here
representative masso yes I'd like to
make a motion
itl motion is to itl do we have a second
second speak to your motion uh
representative masso again I think we've
heard so many concerns about this bill
and how it would affect us that I really
think we need to um itl it for now if it
was a resolution maybe something
different shff well I totally agree
with
okay uh without seeing any hands for
anything new to be added uh Madam clerk
we have an alternative motion of itl
made by representative massamilla
seconded by representative
schliff when you're ready you can call
the role on the
itl this is what you call a pregnant
pause okay representative Rollin No
Representative lungren no representative
levit nope representative Dunn no
representative Gagney no Representative
bogert no Representative lels no
representative Manion NOP representative
shirtliff yes representative Mass Milla
yes representative
spear yes uh yes representative Cary yes
representative Horan yes representative
Judy we Madam representative Lloyd yes
representative Lane yes representative
cert yes and the chair no there you go
so we have nine to n on the itl motion
so neither motion passes this will go to
the floor without any
recommendation uh we we will need
reports um ranion uh you'll do one
report uh for the other side uh ref
mamea if you could get those to me by
1,800 on Sunday that's right before
kickoff yeah okay uh we got the uh that
was one of the big ones uh moving right
along
to HB 1485 that's the uh the bill on the
covid study committee do I have a motion
perhaps from representative gagy you
could be right Mr chairman I motion uh
interim study on
1485 motion is interim study to have a
second I second it representative
lungren seconds representative gagy to
your
motion uh thank you Mr chairman uh
representative Belcher who is the Prime
sponsor of this bill came to us and it
said that perhaps instead of passing
this bill looks like there might be some
work needed to it so he would he
recommended that uh we move it to
interim study and we agreed so I would
ask you to vote Yes on interim
study pres
lren I
agree any other comment Mr chairman uh
represent sherff yeah I think it's a
move point is I think it was brought up
at one of our chairs meetings the
speaker told us he has formed a
committee uh that he's already appointed
people to to study the same time topic
um and so it's like uh I don't think
there's any need even even for an
interim study where speakers already got
this emotion and it could cause
confusion to what he's trying to do and
accomplish I would suggest we move
itl thank you representative
schliff other
comments to representative Sheriff's uh
comment um I am not sure of the status
of the uh I know the prime sponsor
himself as as represent gag he said ask
for he recommended interim study himself
uh I'm not sure where things stand uh
elsewhere so to to be safe and course we
can do an interim study and then uh if
if the other interim studies move for we
don't need to that's fine want bring it
to the attention correct we don't have
to spend time on it if we don't need to
that's a good point anything
else all right Madame clerk the motion
is interim study on HB 1485 when you're
ready representative Rollins yes
representative lren yes representative
lit right representative Dunn yes
representative gagy yes representative
bogert yes representative LEL yes
representative Manion yes representative
shirtliff yes representative Milla yes
representative spear yes representative
KY yes representative Horgan yes
representative Judy we Madam
representative Lloyd yes representative
Lane yes representative Sebert no
no okay so chair
chair chair votes yes okay
so
171 171 uh r c any objection to to uh
consent calendar or would you want to
see this go to the floor you put it on
consent consent it will be no problem no
problem okay thank you all for that
moving right along to hr22 that is the
measure with regard to U uh 13th
Amendment type language on involuntary
servitude uh do we have a motion for
that um are we doing 31 no no this is uh
hr22 22 okay um Christine you want to
make the motion oh oh yeah I motion um
sorry I motion ought to pass on this
one motion from representative seab is
OTP ought to pass an hr22 second from
representative schliff representative
cert uh to your
motion yeah I believe that this is long
overdue um and uh yeah I think that's
all there is to say about that I mean I
think it's uh definitely um we were
again for another week enlightened um to
stuff that is going on and um yeah so I
believe in this and I believe that um I
fully support it so I hope you do too
thank you repres mff
get anyone else Rosa Manion I'm actually
a co-sponsor on this I I firmly believe
that that exception Clause is is super
problematic in the 13th Amendment it it
gives an excuse and actually
incentivizes the government to keep
making victimless crime to throw people
in prison for slave
labor anyone
else seeing No Hands uh Madame clerk the
motion is OTP ought to pass on
hr22 uh when you're ready representative
Rollins yes Representative lungren no
representative levit yes representative
Dunn yes representative gagy yes
representative bogert yes representative
LEL
yes representative Manion yes
representative shirtliff yes
representative Mass Milla yes
representative spear yes representative
krie yes representative Horgan yes
representative Judy we Madame
representative Lloyd yes representative
Lane yes representative Sebert yes and
the chair yes okay
71 you know what Mr chair can I change
my vote to yes yes you can at this point
you I would like to make it
unanimous okay uh representative lren
votes yay
yes that's 18 to zero so 18 to nothing
uh with no no objection we will
recommend that for consan
calendar okay moving right along um HR
HR 27 is the uh the climate related
resolution that I uh introduced this
morning
um so I'll speak very brief I've already
spoken to it at length earlier today so
in in summary all this resolution does
is that a motion did you make I I um
thank thank you representative gagy uh
first things first I I uh would like to
make a motion on HR 27 uh which is uh
OTP
yes that
Judy in
rep I'm
sorry
so reput will play um so representative
Judy uh seconds the OTP motion on HR
27 uh so as I started to say earlier
I've already spoken to it uh in essence
this simply asks that in forming climate
policy that everyone's voices are heard
my the concern of myself and others are
that some voices are being suppressed
and I think for us to make good uh
policy uh here in this house and
elsewhere we need to listen to and
engage everyone uh in an inclusive
fashion uh represent Judy you you second
it you would you like to add or
speak yes Mr chair um for my point of
view we really need a climate uh
policies and it is crucial to consider
like a long-term climate uh policies in
New Hampshire a a dialogue is really
important
important thank you representative you
certainly concur regarding dialogue
anything
else seeing No Hands uh the motion
Madame clerk is uh OTP on the HR
27 representative Rollins yes
representative
lungren yes representative levit yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Gagney yes representative bogert yes
representative LEL yes representative
man
yes Representative shirtliff no
representative Mass Milla no
representative spear no representative
carry no representative Horgan no
representative Judy we Madam
representative Lloyd no representative
Lane no representative Sebert
no and the chair
yes five six seven eight yep 10
next and the count at 108 uh 10 to8 for
OTP I will do a uh a
report um and for the other perspective
do we have a report writer it doesn't
need
to no no report to the
contract necessary okay um then it is on
to
hr26 and we're looking for a motion on
hr26 that has to do with the the
Constitutional Amendment corporate
rights in in that area representative
masso I make a motion not to pass OTP
motion to pass from representative
massamilla on hr26 do we have a
second representative shli seconds uh
representative
M I think listening to the testimony the
um crie sponsor said
that I think it was the Prime sponsor
said
that corporations are not human and I
think that's the bottom line and yes it
it does reference you know citizens
united but it goes back to the railroad
incident that she brought up and I just
think that um since citizens
united uh A lot's taken place that uh
disrupts our politics so
that's
representative sh I can with those
comments I have a a comment and I'm
certainly looking for other comments um
I have to say in all cander that I I
agree with the Supreme Court rulings on
on speech uh Buckley versus valo is
mentioned uh citizens united I I I agree
uh with those uh with all due respect to
the uh Prime sponsor of the
resolution
um with the resolution specifically says
money is not speech uh but the Supreme
Court has essentially said in Sim in
wording similar to to money Visa V
speech that money is part of the First
Amendment uh in terms of you can't stop
someone from spending money on something
that they want to promote uh whether
it's a candidate or a cause uh so money
does equate in my view to to First
Amendment speech rights and that so I I
agree with the the U supreme court on
that and I I could not support this uh
this
resolution
other thoughts um represent Manion yeah
I completely concur with what you're
saying uh the product of your life and
Liberty is your property and your money
is part of your property and you should
be allowed to use your property to speak
freely protected
speech thank you represent cber yeah
sorry
um thank you for taking my question or
comment um so I believe this was more I
took it to be more and what I read is to
be more about corporations not being
people not necessarily about the money
and people it's about the corporations
not being people um yeah so
yeah ripson carry your lights on did you
want to
speak yes I I must be two people I'm a
corporation and I'm a person so
therefore I have double the rights
right is that a rhetorical question
would you
[Laughter]
believe this is exact session so um you
you can just say what you want to say
and u r CA makes a good point I was
focing focusing on the speech which is
part of the resolution the uh the notion
of Corporations being persons uh in law
that's the way it it currently is and I
I think uh that I don't have as strong a
feeling about as I do with the spee
issue um but that is another that's a
second part of this that the prime
sponsor wanted to change that part of it
is not as Paramount to me as the speech
part anything else rip from the lane um
thank you Mr chair um coming from uh
election law which is my regular
committee uh we hear a lot
of uh bills and uh dialogue about
Citizens United and the effect that it
has had on participation by people um in
law a corporation is a person and I
think the testimony made it very clear
that corporates corporations may be
persons for legal reasons but they are
not human and they are not endowed with
the same rights that we have under the
Constitution and they've also been a lot
of evidence and I can't cite it I'm
sorry but there's been a lot of evidence
that um citizens united has really
harmed our constitutional democracy to
the point where
corporations rather than the people are
making a lot more of the decisions
because they have a lot more of money
and they buy ads and they can afford to
do things that frankly I can't do and
maybe many of you could but I can't do
it and I think that my vote and my voice
should count more than a corporations so
that's just my opinion so thank you
thank you representative
Lane anything
else saying no more yes repr Sebert I
make a comment that I'm not going to
vote on um I'm going to vote in favor of
this um largely because I believe that
too many politicians are being bought
out at the state federal level local
level just everything and um yeah so
corporations are pretty much buying out
politicians that shouldn't be allowed so
thank
you thank you
representative yeah yes R
lels yes a question to the committee I
wasn't here when uh the bill was uh uh
was introduced but are labor unions
considered
corporations uh I'm going to go to
representative shirtliff on that
one if call the wrong person you don't
have to say I don't know if they are or
not I don't know if they if they're
Incorporated well they could be they
could be I don't
know L I had the same thought actually
when I was listening to some some of the
comments I I suppressed that question
that you brought forth I think that is
is relevant but uh the again back to the
the motion the motion is OTP on on the
measure uh does anyone else want to
touch represent Lane do you want to
touch on that one I don't know the exact
answer but I can in the sense that labor
unions and corporations have different
rules that apply to them on how they can
give to campaigns for labor unions it
has to come from the members and be
specifically segregated for a
corporation the corporation can make
that decision on its own regardless of
what the shareholders or regardless and
they don't have to have it as a separate
thing
so I I don't know in some context I bet
labor unions are considered to be a
person it purely in a corporate
sense and I don't use corporate to mean
Corporation I just mean like in a
business sense like a limited liability
company or something like that but
that's just my opinion and I'm no longer
practicing law
so that's it note to self representative
Lane used to practice law I need to know
who are potential resources anything uh
representative
Horgan just getting to the the Union
when they they're not allowed to give
campaign donations directly but they all
have packs that are associated with them
and the members can choose to contribute
to the pack or not I it's is full
disclosure I got a few couple of checks
from labor union packs during my last
campaign I don't think I've ever gotten
one from a corporation per se
corporations actually are allowed to
write checks directly to candidates and
campaign committees here here in New
Hampshire and federally but um I mean
they are a corporate entity that there
some somewhat different from a
corporation though but they're type
they're type of corporate entities but I
think we're thinking of Corporations or
like you know Private Business
corporations who are organized very
differently from a labor union
but I I will resist the temptation to
ask for you to elaborate on on the uh
donations that you got bless you um
so uh thank you for that representative
anything else um sing sing No the motion
is uh OTP on
hr26 um Madam clerk when you are ready
uh you can call the role on the OTP
representative Rollins no Representative
lren no representative levit NOP
representative Dunn no representative
Gagney no Representative bogert no
representative LEL no representative
Manion no representative sherli yes
representative Mass Milla yes
representative spear yes representative
Cary yes represent representive Horgan
yes representative Judy we mam
representative Lloyd yes representative
Lane yes representative Sebert yes and
the chair
no okay so nine to
nine nine to nine the OTP mtion motion
does not move forward do we have an
alternative uh alternative I'll motion
itl motion from representative Manion is
itl do we have a second second second is
from representative gagy uh repres
uh me anything new nothing new I think
it's covered representative gagy
second ditto as my esteemed colleague
from the other side said so the motion
is uh to itl is there anyone else who
would like to add anything new and who
made and seconded that the second was
representative gagy gagy are you saw
hand
somewhere just ask members to vote
against that motion um so the prevailing
motion would be the
otpa so the itl
motion is
on
H
hr26 when uh the clerk is ready we'll
call the role on the itl in expedient to
legislate
okay representative Rollin
yes and representative lingren yes
representative lit yes representative
Dunn yes representative gagy yes
representative bogert yes representative
Lal yes representative Manion yes
Representative shirtliff no
representative Mass Milla no
representative spear no representative
KY no representative Horgan no
representative Judy not my
representative Lloyd no representative
Lane no representative Sebert no and the
chair yes
itl okay so Groundhog Day
9 to9 so this will move uh without
recommendation to the full house uh
repes Manion can I look to you for a
report yes before kick off on Sunday uh
uh in for the uh for the other just a
comment Mr chairman I think you meant to
say it'll go to the house with a
recommendation of octop pass uh correct
that technically if it's a Tai vote uh
the OTP motion takes precedent uh thank
you rep represent Sher
so it'll go to the house uh starting
with an OTP Rec recommendation even
though it was a tight 9 to9 vote uh and
still looking for another report
writer I represent mass m thank
you that brings us to hr23 with regard
to uh universal health insurance we
spent a lot of time on that today we
talked about it in our caucuses and
we'll talk about it again and and uh and
vote on it uh is the plan do I have a
motion for
hr23 I'd like to make a motion
representative Lloyd um I'd like to
motion ought to pass representative
Lloyd motions OTP ought to pass on hr23
do we have a second I'll second that
representative cbrt seconds uh
representative Lloyd would you like to
speak to that I think I think that we've
reached a point in American Healthcare
where we need some solutions um it's
kind of as was evidenced by all of the
testimony that we heard we only heard
testimony in support of this um and that
just speaks to how bad the situation is
right now for the everyday individual
just last week I was yelled at by my
surgeon because I went for a little
while without health insurance and
couldn't go see him when I reinjured my
knee um and so there are things that
affect us on a day-to-day basis I was 37
years old I had a skiing accident and I
was in the hospital and had to go
through three four years almost four
years now of physical therapy um and so
one situation can change your luck um so
I just really think that it's important
for all Americans to have some sort of
uh health coverage um so that they don't
have to
worry
repr seber I just um Concur and I want
to add that this is really um about the
doctor your doctor being able to make
your health care or to you know guide
your health care decisions without
having to go through a middleman which
is currently the way it
stands and um yeah so I I'm completely
in support thank you thank you
representative Sebert you mentioned that
this is about the doctors and we have a
a doctor type of person on the committee
uh he is a
doctor do do honest to God do Dr is it
Dr lren it it's fine U I'm against this
and I'll give you the reason why I've
been in healthc care field for 47 years
um I've I've seen uh I'll be very brief
because I'd like to get out of here as
well um
I've seen people come from Canada two
MDS that I know I'm a I'm a DC um to get
the proper Health Care Canada is
Universal Health
Care uh I beg to differ anyway uh
Copenhagen uh I was I spent time in
there for a while same kind of thing
people they it takes them time to get
any kind of care now I heard the doc
this morning talk about or maybe it was
the lady uh 6 hours in the emergency
room well yeah things need to be fixed
but you get care that day some people
are go six months now I'll give you one
one more example uh Ted Kennedy had uh
some kind of cancer all right he was
able to get care immediately because of
his status as a senator where whereas
same people had to wait 6 to 8 months to
get that care so I just I I'm just I'm
against it and I hope I came across okay
even though I'm some kind of a
dog thank you Dr lungren uh
representative Manion who is not a
doctor not a doctor so uh my fears for
any kind of universal healthc care
system came from the one question I did
ask like uh during the pandemic and
shortly there after when the vaccine
mandates were coming down there were
many many Talking Heads on late night
talk shows saying uh well if you don't
get jabbed you don't get health care and
those kind of people would be the voting
individuals that would end up trying
they would end up uh carving the the
procedures and the rules and such like
that from the top down so like this oh
it's going to be Universal unless if you
didn't get the jab you don't get
anything and that's the kind of system
that I cannot possibly
support other hands represent
yes I think I think it's important when
you look at the health care situation
and I think we can all agree that Health
Care is in crisis today we have people
who go to emergency rooms and sit there
for hours and hours and hours to get
care I
I am frustrated by people who who
are afraid of going to the doctor
because they're they're afraid of
bankrupting themselves so we we
definitely have a crisis one of the
advantages of being as old as I am is
that you have the benefit of looking in
the past and if you plot healthc care in
this country and the overall cost of of
health care and if you plot it you'll
see that the line stays fairly level
until it goes zooming
up and that zooming up was the
implementation of Medicare in this
country and with
Medicare the overall cost of medicine
went way up now I'm not sure if you look
at
that whether the quality of Health Care
in this country has kept pace with the
cost and I would I
would caution people who are looking at
this do not
equate coverage with
quality and I think in in so many cases
here very recently we've had changes in
our Health Care system and certainly
more people now have coverage there's no
doubt about
that but has overall quality gone up I I
don't think that's so much of a slam dck
so I'll be voting against that against
this measure because I I think it's such
a
complicated
situation that and I re I Echo
representative
manion's problem is that whenever you
have the government and don't don't
think that this isn't government health
care what this is saying is if you want
Universal Health Care it's run by the
government and I don't think that's a
good thing so I'll be voting against
this thank you representative uh I see
three hands uh as we head down the home
stretch and who who's was first over
here uh repes representative lales I you
stated that as old as you are so were
you treated with herbs when you came
over on the
Mayflower that's a kind of a rhetorical
question of sorts represent mamea has
her hand
up I just wanted to um clarify for Dr
lungren that um this is not socialized
medicine in which the government runs
the health care facilities this is
universal and we got a clarification on
that when um we had the speakers the
other thing is uh this is a reminder
that it's a house
resolution it will go to the feds if we
are likely enough to get it there um so
that's the other part and then there are
are a couple of um misspellings in the
bill if you look
on line 30 it says whereas as small
state New Hampshire cannot I think it
should be whereas a small state like New
Hampshire cannot
provide okay that's on line
30 and then there's one
more I thought it was important we're
going to pass it we can't change it I'm
a teacher she's a teacher I'm a teacher
I'm
sorry and then on line 10 on the second
page it says that the clerk of New
Hampshire House of Representatives is
directed to prepare copies of this
Memorial it's not a memorial maybe a
memorandum
thank you for those two catches I read
that and I didn't know if Memorial and
I'm kind of a word person I didn't know
if Memorial was just another way of of
another uh synonym for this type of
measure that's how I I I just assume
that that OS I've seen that before Mr
chairman so that wouldn't concern you
not in the as versus a uh I one is a
little bit better grammatically than the
other I think they there's no in the uh
in the in the intent or or the
message uh I do want to say to your
point about uh when you made that
question earlier about uh socialized
medicine I think I said that was a good
question and a good answer uh the
doctors I as I understood that would not
be working for the government were this
to go forward they would still be uh
working for themselves or for some other
entity I think that's an important
useful distinction thank you for that uh
reps of
bogert thank you for taking uh my
comment um in listening to the
discussion across here it's a very good
discussion on this and it seemed to keep
coming up with the fact that people go
to have long weight periods to see their
doctor and they have long weight periods
as they go to the emergency room and
stuff but not knowing because I was not
privileged to be here for the uh public
hearing um I do not understand how
Universal Health Care will solve any of
those
problems uh we currently have that
problem today and a majority of the
people have insurance and like as myself
and as I make a doctor appointment it's
3 months mons out they don't care if I
have insurance no insurance or whatever
you're not going to get in to the doctor
because we don't have enough
doctors if you go try and go see one of
your Specialists you're three four
months out from seeing a specialist they
didn't ask if you had insurance or not
and they don't care at that moment when
they're making the appointment they go
there's too many people calling for too
little of service
availability so once again I have to ask
how does Universal Health Care remedy
your weight period in order to see a
doctor it has nothing to do with your
ability to pay it just has the ability
that we don't have enough doctors we
don't have enough specialists in the
state of New Hampshire to cover all the
medical needs that people want to go to
see their doctor for now if we want to
look
at governments taken over
a our our health care um all one has to
say is VA hospital and the VA medical
thing and then tell me how well the
government works with that and do the
comparison and answer that question for
yourself thank you
uh represent sherff you I think you're
going to say what I was about to say
about the VA maybe yes I've gone through
VA for counseling and other things and
the VA is second to none I got
tremendous respect uh for the people
I've dealt with and with all due respect
and my other comment of course was about
the long white beard were you looking at
me when you said that uh no no I'm only
kidding on that part but as far as the
VA goes it's a really is an excellent
and gets a lot of knock but I defer to
the chair
thank you B and thank you oh you you
weren't you were still go ahead and and
finish
um and I'm not trying to discredit the
VA I'm based mine on the the what I hear
in the news uh that there's long wait
periods and times for people to get to
go see the VA and and so I was using
that parallel not the quality not the
quality of the service because no matter
where you go you're going to get high
quality service it had nothing to do
with that it was in relationship to the
amount of time it takes to see a
qualified person you may be right I can
only speak to New Hampshire and they've
been excellent here in New Hampshire
thank you repres bogert uh I was going
to make the same comment uh
representative Sher be me to I'll just
I'll just uh support what he said I have
had some wonderful firsthand experiences
with VA and I am grateful for what they
do do I also know that many people
historically over time have had some bad
experiences which have been highly
public I think they in recent years they
have really worked in to improve their
their uh performance so I I just want to
Echo representative Sheriff's uh comment
there uh yes uh
representative in uh the Commerce
Committee which is my regular committee
we hear a lot about insurance we live
and die by Insurance over there among
other things
uh 6 and 1 12% of the people in New
Hampshire are totally uninsured cannot
afford insurance 24% of people in New
Hampshire are under underinsured in
other words they can get insurance for
part of the year but they can't get
insurance for the rest of the year
because they're Farm Workers or they are
in uh multiple different kinds of uh
employment in order to make enough money
to live in a house or whatever they're
going to live in so this state happens
to be worse than the middle as to
Insurance in this country and
insurance we we make we don't make much
of an effort to get them insured outside
of Medicaid which is a federal uh plan
of a federal
policy we have too many people that have
absolutely no access to Medical Care and
this is not a cheap State this is a
state with a pretty good uh mean medium
income and that's kind of sad so if we
can't do it ourselves maybe we need some
federal
help thank
you other
hand um representative Lloyd I was just
going to comment that um a lot of places
now do require your insurance when you
log in and sign up at for a doctor and
they do check before they allow you to
have that care or that pres that
appointment with your doctor made um I
also can say that while I was on my
employer insurance they decided to
switch plans and I went from a plan
where as you've heard I've had to have
years of physical therapy to be able to
walk and and function again um and uh
they switched from a plan that had
Physical Therapy covered unlimited
numbers $10 a visit that was great they
moved to a new plan next week I go into
my office I show my new card and it's
now $82 a visit and on top of that I I
get it capped at 60
visits so I think really we need to have
some sort of like overreaching um uh or
overarching uh policy in place that
covers these types of things and and
also gaps in employment um I had to stay
with an employer that I did not want to
continue working for anymore because I
you know I I didn't want to work in that
environment anymore and I had to stay on
longer than I wanted to because I needed
that insurance so that I could have
another knee surgery which is what
happened in March
so thank you
representative representative Lane thank
you um um two two points one personal um
my my son uh was working various jobs
and his employer did not really provide
health care and he was not making enough
money to afford to buy in so he went a
long time in a fairly risky profession
um without insurance which of course did
not make his mother very happy um but I
mean he he's you know in the 30s so I
think there's a lot of people out there
that we assume have health insurance
that really do not and they're not
covered he was above the amount to get
full coverage but then he he was in that
Gap and there was nothing really he
could could do so fortunately um he was
able to borrow some
money from from from the mom ATM but I
just it was very unsettling and and most
of there were a lot of people and it
really opened my eyes um to the issue
secondly I spent um 10 years working as
a legal aid attorney and I can say that
legal bills you know strap because when
you go in without insurance there's a
different rate that you pay and that
you're expected to pay and the bills are
crippling and most people just don't
have that kind of money and while
nationalization may not be the answer I
have not heard any other solution that
seems to make sense so for that reason
I'll support this but we definitely need
to do something and I know it's beyond
the purview of this committee but um and
and New Hampshire is too small to do it
on our own we can't do it so thank you
thank you
representative um seeing no more oh I
see two hands going up and down uh who's
in them represent Horgan yes of course
you of course I filled out a pink card
during the hearing which was two and a
half hours ago but um just to reiterate
I've been on a single-payer federal
government Health Plan Medicare for
years and it's um worked out fairly well
for well for me the uh and you can get
supplement plans go on top of it um
because they only pay a certain
percentage but then it's up to you to
either pay for it out of your own funds
or get a supplemental insurance plan by
private insurance companies I think that
has worked well um also all the care of
getting those EOB forms are pretty
bizarre you know especially the number
in the leand of the column is way out of
is always like several orders of
magnitude more than what I actually have
to pay but um the
Medicare and um but I think the Medicare
has been good for that in fact a lot of
times when you're paying for something
out of your own pocket because you don't
have insurance they often like if it's
something relatively inexpensive they'll
just say well we'll charge you the
Medicare rate and if you have the money
to write a check for that that's usually
how they handle it and before that I was
for several years I planned for the
Affordable Care Act um that worked
better than anything I did before parti
and one of the reasons fary because that
also set a standard certain standards
that the providers and the patients
understood so before that it was total
chaos you know especially with find R
the problem tying Insurance to employers
um every plan is different and employers
are often quite eager to not let you be
eligible for the insurance you know like
just there's various ways around that so
that and then trying to get something at
least if you're older and even
apparently even like repr Lane's son
through the private Market the free
market is really there's a large
percentage of people the free market is
just not interested in surfing you know
so um thank you
representative L did you have your hand
up go sure I I would just like to Echo
what my friend representative shirtless
said about the VA as a disabled
veteran uh I've had literally millions
of dollars spent on my body and I it
might not look like it but I've I've
gotten a lot of good out of that they
every time I go into the hospital in
Manchester I'm treated like a king
and
uh I I would just like to thank the
people of this country for what they've
done for me uh in this case
uh it's it's important that we do
something because we are in crisis
um but I'd just like to Echo what Steve
said about the VA the money was well
spend thank you representative I I
trying not to mention the $6 Million Man
from um but that was uh back in the 70s
other
hands seeing no more hands the motion on
the floor is OTP ought to pass on
hr23 uh Madam clerk that's our motion
when you're ready
Rollins uh no representive lren no
representative levit NOP representive
Dunn no Representative gagy no
Representative bogert no representative
LEL no representative Manion no
representative shirtliff yes
representative Mass Milla yes
representive spear yes representative
Cary yes representative Horgan yes
representative Judy Madame
representative
Lloyd representative Lane
yes represents
Sebert
yeah okay and the chair no there you go
Groundhog
Day so we have a nine to n vote uh
representative Manion do you have an
alternative uh yes I'd like to motion
itl is there a second uh I'll second
that uh to to your uh to your
motion represent Manion uh no I have no
no additional I I have nothing new we we
have spent a lot of time on this does
anyone else have anything
new okay uh if the the role uh Madam
clerk when you're ready this time the
motion is
itl okay representative
Rollins
yes representative lungren yes
representative levit yep representative
Dunn yes representative gagy yes
representative bogert yes representative
LEL yes representative Manion yes
Representative shirtliff no
representative Mass Milla no
representative spear no representative
kry no representative Horgan no
representative Judy no Madam
representative Lloyd no representative
Lane no representative
Sebert no
okay and the
chair yes to ilt itl okay Groundhog Day
9 to9 so this will be handled the same
way the previous measure was uh when as
it goes to the house floor uh I'll do a
a report and uh who else would like to
do a
report uh do we have a report I'm sure
we must have a
report
um Russ Manion do did that Amendment
ever come in for H I was just checking
on this but I was distracted I did
forward it to the committee it did it
came in I can print it out I okay we'll
take a five minute recess we have one
more measure five minute
recess
they were working on an amendment
right
hey folks we're just waiting for some
guidance on the one measure we still
have left uh we'll we'll get give you
that word just
momentarily
represent CRA were you going to do the
report on the uh involuntary servitude
uh I'm just trying to get my notes in
order here was was that
you I don't remember it being made
that's you going to do
it
we still have to do a
report that yes that's hr22
yes all right thank you repon Sebert
um it's it's
unanimous
thank you Christina okay the the one
remaining motion it's a a measure is a
little bit complicated it's hr31 we uh
uh initially had it scheduled and the
sponsors asked for uh a recess or more
time uh and now there's an amendment so
we at this time we need to recess on
that uh I'm told uh hr31 to a date
certain and so what we can do and will
do at this time is uh because it's just
one simple measure with one sponsor uh
we should be able to uh meet as a
committee on Thursday immediately after
the session and uh deal with it so
that's what I am going to do at this
time on hr31 and we're going to rece
recess it to a date certain that date
certain is this coming Thursday the 15th
uh and we will
gather U IM
immediately uh question was can we do it
on Monday and we checked on that and
there the timelines don't work they they
need so uh yes uh we were that would
have been preferable if we could have
done that but we want to do everything
legal around here because this is state
federal could just announce that from
well correct on session day so those of
you most of you pres presumably uh
will be here on Thursday so we'll make
we'll make the announcement on the floor
we will and probably probably come here
have have the uh executive session on
that one measure which should not take
very long and then we'll be done so
that's that uh are there any questions
for for me or anything else I think we
have all the report writers
representative bogert yes I just wanted
uh one more time um about my statement
about the VA it had nothing to do with
the quality of the service that they
were provided and I wanted to make sure
I was
not making that statement what I was was
comparing the length it takes to get an
appointment in general with the medical
field and going to the hospital oh sure
fully understood representative
representative
lungren the chair we we meet at 1 p.m.
on Thursday that's correct it's the uh
in the morning is the State of the State
and then we we convene at 1 1 p.m. in
rep's hall for a session yes and you
want to do this after is that what
you're saying that's what I just
announced yes okay and so the goes at
the conclusion of the full session we
we'll have an executive session on that
on that final measure yes how about if
we did it before the 1M start uh I'm
looking at Christina who I think
that's great I'm sorry I she was saying
that we we need to announce it on the
floor as the protocol okay uh so before
after we've already I've already made
the announcement that we will uh
announce it on the floor we'll we'll
meet right afterwards and take care of
it in in exec
it okay so that will be Thursday the
15th any anything else I think we have
all our report writers thank you
especially representative seir
especially representative
uh we don't spread things out equally
here some people uh are more equal than
others in terms of writing reports uh
and thank you for what you do uh we
usually meet on Fridays I ask for him by
6: pm on Sunday so I can get them done
Sunday night and in on Monday so thank
you for that uh those of you who are
report writers I will get with uh the
ranking member we'll need to uh uh
confirm speeches uh for both this coming
Thursday and the following in Thursday
speeches and pis we'll nail those down
uh soon uh anything else for the good of
the
order uh okay thank you subs for uh for
being here we'll see everybody uh we'll
see in
conquered